It should be live here.
Set the category.
Okay, I'm happy to just have that uh
doing whatever. There is fine.
There's Volo. Perfect.
How's it going, man?
merge. Let me merge so I have a clean
thing to work off of with you.
The heck is wrong with this?
Oh,
Talk about genetic algorithms. Welcome
guy who comes to talk about genetic
algorithms.
pull in repro.
I can do that.
Welcome. We are currently going to be
pulling in uh
follows Runescape environment.
It's typed.
Is this a PR vol or is it the current
version?
I think this is just like a we have to
merge and try this.
I'm doing this right, aren't I?
The current change.
Yes.
A life is artificial life. It's a
conference.
One merge thing from my current changes
and one merge thing from yours.
Just a small merge uh merge issue I
suppose.
Uh,
I am able to I don't know if I pushed
there was one small fix with obs T that
it needed.
I'm getting that fixed right now. Yeah,
I can jump on. You cool being on stream
vol or you want me to do off stream's
discord.
Okay, that should work.
say something.
>> Okay, cool. So, I've been wanting to get
this end of merged in for a long time.
Yeah, let's see. Um,
so I got Inferno here. I'm going to see
if I can get this to run on the 5090 box
first and eval.
Uh, you should be able to hear Volo.
>> Yeah, I can. I just reprod 90 bucks as
well, so should be all right.
>> It is a 27 minute run at the
>> one that I had initially in the
description of the VR. So
>> you're getting like 40% wins or
something like that. So
>> 40% wins.
>> Yeah, that's No, that's still good
because you simplified a lot of stuff,
right?
>> I did. Yeah, is down to like 530 or
something. So
it was well above 2,000 at some point.
So that's uh
>> and
let me see while we while we do this
while this runs by taking a look at it.
This seems to work.
>> Yeah, I don't really even know I don't
know about the bottlenecks to be honest.
It's very hard for me at this point to
even like think about the
First, we take a look at config. So,
immediately this has a async off. This
was the major optimization of puffer 5.
Um, sometimes needs reweeps to be
stable, but this is very good,
especially for slow environments because
it lets you keep the GPU spinning the
whole time that the end is spinning.
What does it do?
>> Uh it allows you to have one exactly one
epoch of asynchronous policy drift. So
essentially you're collecting data one
epoch behind what the policy is
optimizing. Off policy drift is very
bad. This constrains you to a very small
amount of off policy drift in order to
have essentially perfect CPU GPU
overlap.
Fair enough. and it's soda on
everything. Um, there was some drift,
but like once everybody retuned all
their ends, this is soda on everything.
>> Um, so that's one thing you can do.
Let's take a look at
>> You said it's probably going to need a
sweep still.
>> Yeah, it will need a sweep, which no big
deal, but that's a thing. So, total
agents is a little bit low.
Um,
>> yeah, sweeping for this as well. And for
some reason, it just keeps pushing it to
2K.
>> It's probably because the NV is slow,
honestly.
It's probably because the N is slow.
>> It could be I've optimized it a ton to
be honest the last however long. So
>> yeah like the parameters
>> can be at this point but
>> the parameters I am seeing here are
indicative of
yeah the parameters that I am seeing
here are indicative of a slower end like
small mini batch
and such. Um I also see that you have a
bunch of these stale coefficients. These
have been deleted. So these args no
longer exist in puffer 5 and you can
possibly need to reweep because of this
as well. This is like a 10%ish lift to
training performance as well. Um it also
notably in 5 we changed the advantage
function norm. It doesn't normalize
advantage. That can also sometimes cause
a need for reweep but it usually works
better after you do. I see very high
replay ratio which is again indicative
of a slower env. But then the key thing
that's weird with that's bad with this
is this is not overlapped. So it's
basically doing a bunch of steps on the
end and then doing a bunch of training
steps and not overlapping them at all.
This is exactly the scenario that async
is built for
>> I like how I have Joseph reward mode in
here
>> and it's still there.
>> I do think it matters that it's it's a
longer horizon problem. It's like I
don't know how long these episodes are.
>> We have lots of long horizon problems
though to be fair. It's the thing that
matters for this horizon is not the
length of the total episode, but it's
the length of like the amount that you
need to consider at any one time. And
256 is not butdding up against the
maximum. So this should be fine. I think
that this is generally this is fine.
Yeah. The big thing I see there is the
big optimization I see there. Um
oh wait, hang on. Vec numbum buffers.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This vec config
is screwy.
Let me show you this.
>> Oh, I didn't even notice that. So, if
you check num, we have a default num
thread 16 num buffers 2.
I'm a little suspicious actually of that
one. So, yeah, this one's num one and
eight. Typically for ends like this, you
probably you need more buffers I would
think at the least
because that also allows you to overlap
inference compute with the environment.
So I think it's probably just
vectorization settings alone can get you
quite a bit out of this. After this
trains, I can just see really quickly if
uh if we can do anything with this. See
how this is going.
Are you sure that we are overriding
those um the default config ones with
this one?
>> Oh yeah, the overrides definitely work
>> but um num buffers here
>> uh one is this is small. This
essentially means that it cannot overlap
the environment compute with the rollout
compute
>> at least with this goal earlier. So,
>> Mhm.
>> I mean, they're just some common things
I know how to play with.
>> Yeah.
>> 270k with all that's not bad. I see 35%
on the EN. So,
>> I think the N alone runs something like
800k maybe
>> vectorzed 800k.
>> Yeah, it's pretty good.
>> We should be able to get it pretty close
to 800k train then.
I think at least 2x on this.
>> Yeah. where it has a ton of replay, I
suppose, now as well. And uh
>> well, the replay becomes free.
>> Yeah.
>> Also, I think I broke the train stats.
I'll have to fix that.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I I just must have broken train
stats. Um I'll fix that.
>> Yeah, this is a bigger model in my
latest sweep, but I didn't really really
got anything super great for 256 width
models. So
>> we can train I mean this model we can
train this at many millions of steps per
second models this size.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I also you do have a pretty do you
have a pretty fancy custom encoder?
>> I don't know about that really just
builds on the on the NCD encoder but
>> Oh just built on Okay. I don't know if
you've profiled that to see how much of
the time is in the encoder. That's a
pretty nice thing to do. Actually, I
have this little side. I call this
fishing in a sense because I'm just
seeing if I happen to get anything out
of the LLM slot machine. I have a even
an intentional encoder up to apparently
up to 10 mil SPS.
>> So, like you can definitely make things
very fast.
>> Um,
>> but it does take quite a bit of a
blading to get there.
>> Let's see. So, this is
>> what we have. We are wave 50.8. Is this
with curriculum still?
>> It is. Yeah.
I swear the precise checkpoints and
fractions and whatnot. You can find them
there.
>> Wave curriculum wave 1 equals 67.
>> What is this?
>> This is 70 and 71. They are the uh ones
that you actually came up with
initially. So that's like healers maybe.
71 something like that. So
>> Okay. Okay.
But it doesn't like it for some reason.
It seems
>> sir. Yeah, it's a lot of coefficients to
sweep to be fair. This is a lot a lot of
coefficients to sweep.
>> Is Yeah.
>> Um we do get to delete four hypers.
>> Like we actually at least we get to
delete four hypers from sweep with 50.
>> Yeah,
>> that helps a little bit.
>> But yeah, I mean this is to me this is
like this is typical like this config
that is found. This is typical of a slow
environment or slow vec setup. And when
the environment gets slow, it also
starts cranking up the compute. So it
gets even slower. Whereas it's funny
when you have a fast environment, it
picks fast range configs and everything
gets faster. It's kind of
self-compounding
in a way.
>> Yeah, I definitely noticed that in my
latest round of optimizations after you
said this initially. Yeah,
>> definitely true. that async
>> I mean it makes sense like if the
environment is slow to begin with then
you know just
>> then it spends more comput why not
>> yeah exactly exactly it does spend more
compute um and it does it also kind of
shifts your understanding in a way this
is still not bad for a scaleup end I
mean I think net hack is a little bit
faster than this I think net hack is to
3 to 400k
um we can definitely get this to be
faster as well I would say yeah we can
definitely this is about the same as net
hack then we can get this faster though
for Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's not terrible. It's It's been
terrible at points like 30k something
like that. I had a ton of observations.
>> Yeah. You can't really do much at 30k.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. What What should I look at
here? I see the This is the net file, I
suppose.
Branch descriptor.
Okay. Where's the actual encoder?
It's in the place where it should be
nowadays
>> which is
>> somewhere in ocean. Is it under the um
environment itself?
>> I see entity.
Is it here?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Got a bit of a delay in
streams.
>> I can stream Discord too if that's
easier.
>> Does it not let me do this? What? Yes,
it does.
There
>> stream quality more option.
See if that's any better.
I stream it on Discord, too, as well
now. That should be less laggy.
>> Yeah, it's just under Ocean and Allars.
You're looking at it.
this is adapted from our entity encoder.
Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Do do you know 16?
It's been a couple weeks.
>> It looks like it kept the 16 dim.
>> Yeah,
>> I think uh this architecture does not
work if you increase the hidden size of
the intermediate layer. The intermediate
layer has to be max 16 dim.
>> Did I have I explained this before? So
if um here
it's it's kind of a clever like
non-intentional architecture where you
have like lots of entities right each of
these needs to get encoded identically.
So how do you do this? Well each of
these is going to go to
a 16
Oops.
And this is 16 width.
So if we think of the data here, this is
16 times the n of entities n entities.
You have initial dimension per entity,
but it always goes to 16. And then the
key thing here is that you take these
into a bigger projection.
So this is to h this is h * n right
and then the question is well like how
does this help you because you this is a
lot of data right h* n is a huge amount
of data but what you do is this actually
gets maxed
into just h
and the thing is you never materialize
this. So this is so this is never
material. So you never actually have H
byN. And I've tried several ways of
doing it. There's no way to drag this
layer through.
So basically you have to materialize
this.
You have to materialize the
intermediates. You don't have to
materialize the last layer.
So, you're limited here, but you're not
limited here. That makes sense, right?
>> Okay, fair enough.
>> Yeah, I'm actually I'm working on Well,
I have I'm fishing for I shouldn't say
I'm working on I'm fishing for an entity
encoder architecture.
>> Um, we'll see if it works,
like an intentional one.
>> We'll see. But the horse specifics are
pretty much stuff that you'd already
understand being a player yourself.
It's, you know, the inventory
>> viewer.
I'm excited about this then because we
have right now, this is very good
timing. Uh Finn also has. Have you ever
played Net Hack?
>> I have not. No.
>> Okay. Net Hack is uh DN D as an ASI
terminal dungeon crawler.
>> Okay. And when I say D and D, I mean
like actually imagine that 15 autistic
nerds attempted to model D and D as damn
closely as they possibly could with
every possible interaction of everything
for 15 years.
>> So it's a ludicrously detailed sim. Um
and it's in a sense like if you solve
that with RL, you've solved RL and
you've probably solved AI.
>> Um so he has that as well. that's his
main project for the rest of the summer
uh as an intern and he's been he's
already way way way above soda but we
have the same problem there where it's
an entity encoder and he can see that
like I've been having him do mechanistic
interpretability work on that as well
um and we can clearly see that it
doesn't fully understand its inventory
and it's probably an encoder limitation
so I think that what's likely here is
that your Runescape ends together with
net hack together with my synthetic
tests will let us figure out that
architecture and then just fully solve
this problem
and then you'll have a really cool demo
on this but also we'll we'll have that
architecture that we know works
generally.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> And this is exactly why I wanted to have
like MS like this is because they expose
problems like this that we don't have
fully modeled yet, right? Like when you
have something that you can just stick
into flat encoder puffer solves, when
you have something more structured, it
gets hard. And this is actually um this
type of stuff was I think I probably
spent more time on this exact type of
problem in my PhD than anybody else in
the world. Um that was like the major
thing with neural MMO.
>> So yeah, I'm well aware of the
difficulty of this.
>> Oh yeah, for sure.
>> Okay, so we have
same entity encoder. Cool.
This is all that's in here.
Okay, cool. So, you use this for
inventory.
What do you do for enemies? Is this also
for enemies?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> And equip gear as well.
>> And equip what?
>> Yeah, our gear. Equip gear. So, the 11
slots that we've got.
>> Okay, hang on. Let me pull Let me here.
Let me just go pull something up.
Uh, we will get a we'll get an example
here.
Oops. Hang on. As I want to figure out
how you've modeled this.
Uh, I just grabbed some stuff.
Whatever.
So,
equipping gear. Like, how does it see
this? It just sees each item has an
embedding.
>> Yeah.
Okay, so we have embedding for ancestral
robe, embedding for ferro gloves,
embedding for threads, and then the
action space, it has 28 slots.
>> Yes, 28 slots. And then I just divide it
by the slots of um
of the gear gear piece, the gear slots.
>> Is it encoder though? Like so there's a
way that we could do
like so there's entity encoder and
there's entity decoder here right so
>> and I think Finn's already been doing
this with net hack but this is again
stuff from from PhD
uh so let's see we have a
There are two ways you could do this,
right? You could just do like max
whatever in code
and then you could go to
or actually it would be like this
0 one two. Do you do this or do you do
now I have
basically the the items have their like
content codes as I call it. So you can
think about it just as the name of the
item or the ID of it.
So
really just knows the separate items.
And
>> is this like cosign sim?
>> Well, no, I don't I don't check that.
No. So you have 28 inventory cells.
>> Mhm.
>> And then for each of those, it decodes
the kind of like scalar content code
that I have for each of the items. And
then all of the all of the items have
these features, you know, like is it a
armor? Is it a piece of armor, a weapon,
or is it like a food or a potion or
whatever? Then some stats like attack
speed, attack range, whatnot. And then
we project those features to the U 16
feature representation.
>> Okay. Right. So this is this stage here,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay. But then from this you can
directly decode this to slot 1 through
28 or 0 through 27.
>> Right? That's one thing you could do.
>> But the much better thing that you can
do is an entity decoder. So just like
this is an entity encoder. You can do
entity decoder. And the way that you do
this
>> is that like this hidden size now this
has the embedding information from
everything, right? But it includes not
just the entities here. This includes
like terrain. This includes everything
else, right?
Yeah.
>> So when I So like what happens if you
just take dotproduct here,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> This can give you this score instead of
just doing like this is an entity
decoder like from pointer nets.
>> Yeah, fair enough.
>> Do you have this or do you have just
like the flat decoder?
>> I don't have that now.
>> Okay. So the flat decoder, if you think
about the inductive bias that you have
to learn with the flat decoder, um it
has to learn separately like every item
in every slot, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So that's pretty tricky.
It doesn't get the order invariance. It
doesn't get like the selection bias like
if I So the entity encoder means that on
the OB side, if I do this, right? If I
just move my gear, if I move my gear
around,
the encoder gets the exact same thing,
right? Before versus now, doesn't
matter. But the decoder doesn't get the
same thing.
>> The decoder gets something completely
different.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
Um, so you know, even I guess if you
have the fixed gear order, it's kind of
fine,
>> but then
I I think if you just switch a few
things, right? Like it should get messed
up pretty pretty quickly if I just like
have
>> Hang on. Let me see. I'm pretty sure
that it gets messed up.
You do like this. In
>> the case of the decoder, it would then
>> Well, I just order,
but like it doesn't matter for the
encoder.
Yeah, it doesn't matter for the encoder.
I was just trying to think like, okay,
if I switch in a different order, if I
do this and then I do this, like now the
the order gets messed up, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, like you are not it's not like you
just have one order that the agent has
to learn anyways. Like while it switches
and does stuff, it'll get messed up.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I know. But right now we just use
them.
>> Yeah, I So I do think probably entity
decoder and I I'll ask Finn if he has
like some sample that you can just point
whatever cla or whatever at. Um
>> yeah,
>> I would think that that would probably
help quite a lot. And I can specifically
let let me actually let's just message
Finn real quick.
But in terms of the inventory items like
how does it help with understanding the
dynamics between the items or the
policy? I don't really understand
>> how does how does the encoder or how
does the decoder help?
>> The decoder that you have in mind. So
the thing that the decoder lets you do
is
right now the way your decoders works is
it says pick a number 1 through 27.
Okay. When you have an entity decoder it
says pick an item.
>> So the interpretation is it picks the
embedding of ancestral rope top
>> and it compares the similarity between
this. It computes a score between this
and the hidden vector and then this has
high score because it wants to equip the
ancestral top. So it equips this and
it's like if you move the ancestral top
here for instance the logits will not
change.
>> Yeah.
>> So literally the entire network will be
completely invariant to the ordering of
your inventory.
>> Okay, that makes sense. Yeah, I tried to
accomplish this same kind of thing with
the observations
>> says he has an entity.
Yeah, I was I was running like
calculations on the basically the OSRS
DPS calls. You already know know those
tools like I was
>> Oh yeah,
>> running those uh every for setups and
like alternative setups and whatnot. So
that was massive junk. But yeah,
>> yeah, I remember. No, it's way better
now. I I don't think that you need any
of that stuff. I just I think that
specifically the inductive bias of
entity decoder should help. Yo, Finn, if
you're here, do you have entity encoder
code that he could like point um point
whatever model at to like see if he can
port it for RS? Because I think it would
probably make a big difference because
Runescape has the exact same problem as
uh as Net Hack with the inventory
ordering. Um
>> yeah, I can take a look.
>> This was a pretty major thing for my PhD
and this has been used in a lot of the
bigger game things as well. Yep, it
makes perfect sense.
>> Post sign attention on items, I assume,
is what you mean.
>> Yep. Okay. Net hack.cu. So, yeah, if you
just go grab um if you just point this
thing at at um binsnet hack.cu, you can
snag the entity decoder.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh there's no Runescape rule breaking
going on here. This is a research
project. All of this is done in
simulation. Nothing is run on the main
game.
>> Yeah, it's fine. The window I showed up
was just my main for like comparison,
like trying to explain something with
the item representation. We're not
running any scripts on the main game.
>> Always the same questions.
>> Yes.
>> Please don't break my favorite game.
>> Yeah, I'm fire making as we speak. So,
>> uh,
>> Is it chill?
>> Was
Oh, is
>> Yeah, it's decently. It's like a minute
between.
>> Wow. Well, way better than the previous.
>> Yeah, way better. And it's 1350 XP drop
as well plus waiting. So like 1,500 on
average per interaction.
>> Yeah, it's one big XP drop. That's like
dopamine.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's pretty good.
>> I did I already I finished it by making
I finished these. These are done.
>> No.
>> Oh,
227.
This is the old MarkX, isn't it? Yeah,
it literally is. It just so happens to
be exactly that.
>> No, this is going to be so cool though.
>> Way to go.
>> I I think for people like that don't
have context from the game on like how
stupidly complicated Inferno and Colot
gets like it might be hard to
appreciate. Like you can see it doing
some cool stuff on the game, but you
kind of have to at least know the game
somewhat to understand how ludicrously
impressive it is.
Yeah, and the game itself is massive.
Imagine like we only have Inferno and
Coliseum and you know some prototyping
elsewhere. But
>> even this is a ton of work. Of course, a
lot of it is loaded, but yeah,
>> every so often John drops into stream
and it seems like he's still been
working on the core engine a lot.
I'm really hoping he has something
that's like nice and compact
uh for like overworld stuff where maybe
we could either port your stuff on or
like combine things cuz that would be so
cool. Like imagine just having a whole
bunch of different encounters where we
can just drop an agent, right, with the
same encoding
>> or just nearby entities inventory, you
know, standard encoder decoder. Pretty
simple. just drop it anywhere and just
have it do lots of different bosses and
then maybe even try to get lots of
different scenarios on same policy.
>> Exactly. Yeah,
>> I think we do have some server logic
nowadays like that 2004 scape for
example. I think it's open source so I
could try and port some of that stuff
but you know
>> mostly the mechanical correctness. Um,
>> yeah, true. That I've spent so much time
on already. So, like I'm fairly
confident about the basics be like path
finding or whatnot, but of course
there's so much.
>> Have you just like messed around in it
and try to do like tried to do all the
basic tech like can I do tick blowpipe
walk with this? Can I take path
correctly? You know?
>> Yeah. Well, the basic stuff I have, but
then you've got this like portasard
stuff that's just way up.
>> Okay.
Yeah, that's um
>> so I I know for a fact that he doesn't
have all of that, but then also I'm
that's lower priority right now to me
because like I'm just trying
>> it's not going to find that.
>> Yeah. Well, yeah.
>> It probably some some sort of obscure
stuff like correct red Xing it might
need
um it might figure some stuff out like
that. It definitely needs basic tech
like redemption.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, really not in that phase of this
yet. Like I just want to test all of
these like wonky setups and whatnot, but
like let's first solve it with the max
range and max mage. Oh yeah. To begin
with,
>> well yeah, the next thing after that you
could do like um pure inferno or
whatever.
Yeah,
>> it's I think that it will work though
because most of the difficulty you've
had is actually with Zuck, isn't it?
>> Well, it used to be uh after we got the
rewards down, it's not that bad anymore.
I suppose it's just like an RL
learnability problem. It's just so
different from the rest of the rest of
the thing. burn.
>> I gave a whole bunch of ideas on like
Mechinterp stuff that I think the net
hack insights will generalize
>> because it is basically just like most
of the time when stuff doesn't work,
it's cuz the agent can't actually see
correctly.
>> Yeah.
>> Is this going? Oh, this is done. So, we
have
uh 4% wins here.
4% is way less than I expected.
>> We might have to retune.
>> Yeah, I wonder if this is now the
>> We can retune this though. This is not
bad to retune at all, man.
>> So, let's let me check let me check a
couple things with this. So, first of
all,
>> um I guess we commit this. Let's bring
this down so I can just we can watch it
and then I'm going to see if I can speed
it up a little bit.
>> Yes, you did see me
>> you didn't really see me working on an
attention in Kodafin. You saw me fishing
for one. I think it is very likely we
have a 10 mil step per second attention
encoder though. Um, we can chat about
that once I know that it's not just LM
crap. I was trying to get it to soda
neural MMO to like prove itself. I think
we do have uh a 10m SPS attention
encoder. It will be limited in size,
but it does solve the minimal end at 10
mps and I know you need attention of
some sort to solve that.
Okay. Um,
yes. Next thing. So,
what do we do here? Status.
I think I have to commit the entity crap
in order to have the stable, which is
fine.
I'm actually going to make this easier
on us.
You turned up changing something in the
conflict.
>> What's that?
>> Did you change something in the conflict
that you just rewrote this on
>> my spirit?
>> Yeah. You didn't did you tune this on 50
though?
>> I did, but I don't know how long it's
been. It's only been a week or so since
I
>> I changed I changed something major with
the advantages in the last week.
>> Okay.
I got to got to rebase again. But it's
still not too bad. Like average wave of
what 65 was it? So
>> yeah, I'm not worried about it, man.
You'll get the same perf or higher if
you've had it before. Um
>> yeah,
>> it's just a sweet I'm not worried about
that. Like
>> Yeah.
I can do CPU. Oh, does it take CPU to
build
the data?
>> I think I had it on already. I don't
think you really need it.
Uh
>> oh.
Now, this doesn't Why does this not
render?
Why did you pass the CPU fog?
>> I tried that before.
>> Okay,
>> hang. But good. Like, let me I'll
rebuild and show you. It builds a
different binary now, so that doesn't
matter.
So actually I have it for 100 a month
from a promo for the first few months.
We'll just let's just get rock to figure
out.
>> Yeah.
>> Actually, let me make sure.
Let me just make sure this works.
Oh,
>> that's weird.
So, apparently there's some crossover
here.
>> Yeah, there has to be. I just smoked
this on the Cuda box as well here.
>> I It's like this is dev branch. I don't
care if things are broken for two hours
while we troubleshoot this
more than Claude or Codeex.
They have they have max plans as well,
don't they?
I mean, they have cheaper plans with
lower limits.
This could just be binding change,
right? Because puff render.
>> Yeah, it would have to be
>> is fast. Exactly. Okay, so this is why I
literally have floating above my head
cuz everybody asked me about the stupid
models rock because fast.
That's why.
>> Yeah, with this medium reasoning it's
goes.
>> Yeah, guys, I don't I don't know and I
don't care about the model indexes. I
want it to be good enough that it can
follow directions for the most part and
not make me sit here for two hours.
If it makes mistakes, I know like I can
fix them.
Yeah, the LLM usage is the least
interesting part of the work going on
here.
Seriously,
>> this is This must have just been a bad
merge, right?
>> Yeah, I think it has to be. Is it
working just fine?
Well, we definitely get the renderer
locally.
>> And does this Have you tried building
this for web yet?
>> I can't. Yeah, also have it on my like
blog site or whatever up already, but
>> Okay, awesome.
>> Yeah, cuz we have
>> Have you seen this?
So, we have not this. This is ocean
right now as of puffer five. I don't
have the server running, I don't think.
But look at all the ends.
Yeah,
>> we have a lot. Oh, yeah, it does work.
So, we're going to try with Finn to get
a web build of Net Hack if we can.
I don't think we're going to get into
trouble if we put the Runescape
ones on here. Like,
>> no, I don't think
>> it's not licensed like the Colo sim and
stuff. The Sims that they have online
aren't licensed already, right?
>> Yeah. They have creators constantly
using their assets for trailers and
stuff as well.
>> Yeah.
>> So like
I mean maybe because it's AI but like
we're not botting the game so I doubt
it.
>> That's the only thing that I'm like
worried about is if Jagex thinks that
somebody could just hijack all of his
code and then turn it into a bot. But
then again like if you want to write a
bot then you just write a bot. It's
>> Yeah.
But yeah, everybody doesn't know. Uh,
this guy John B from Discord, he also
linked me this like sim.gg
simulator which is like a new
TypeScript. So I mention some like web
simulator has yama and everything like
everybody's now working on this.
>> Oh really?
>> Imagine we trend though. So
>> if you can figure out engine stuff from
there, like you can probably yoink logic
very easily into C and then like just
have Puffer doing more bosses.
>> Yeah. Well, it's not open source that
one. So
>> Oh,
>> I don't know if anybody's done any of
the like interesting end game bosses
open source yet.
>> I see.
>> Other than Infernal. It's the only one
that I know of.
>> Wait, who's building that uh the
TypeScript one?
>> What's that?
>> Who's building the TypeScript one? I
don't know. It's some group. It's
clearly AI, but like it's it's still
pretty nice. It's actually like plays
well. So,
but I imagine they've all they've built
on the same stuff that I have. It's like
OSR's SDK. Basically, the same thing
that powers the Infernal Trainer and
whatnot. So,
>> uh Okay, let's see.
Oh, wait. You have a standalone?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Buffer balls should work perfectly fine
as well.
If it doesn't, then I'm supposed to send
you one.
World Labs. It's very cool. I visited
there uh last summer, I think.
I don't really think it was good for RL,
but I think it's good for something.
Yeah, I think it's cuz you have the
standalone. Did you ever have this wired
for CUDA eval?
>> Oh, yeah, it's wired right now. I don't
know what something in the merge must
have broken it, but
>> Okay.
I think probably it'll find whatever
existing hooks then weren't wired.
>> Yeah.
Oh, the other thing is no it is C it is
C++
compatible or very easily will be
concept is to predict isn't it? Uh not
really compression of objective and the
policy learning objective are quite
different.
I'm actually interested to see uh Volo
where it's a little annoying because
this does get this gets messed up by
this type of thing will get messed up by
ends being slow.
But this is sort of a mockup I had with
real data for constellation.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So this is the number of parameters in
the network. This is the number of flops
and this is the fastest or the lowest
flop uh above 0.95% perf on all these
ends.
>> You can very clearly see that there's a
difficulty scaling to ends and there's a
very clean network size versus flop
scaling as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Right
now this is still spanning like two or
three orders of magnitude. Two orders of
magnitude but you can still see very
cleanly. Right.
>> Yeah.
You don't have some of the you have
neural MMO here for example.
>> Uh because it was it doesn't have a 0.95
solved. So it just filtered everything
in the mockup.
Neural MMO is currently
I think it's like twothirds solvedish
as of the best little less than two/ird
solved as of the current best model
after the bug fix. Uh and that's in only
20 minutes instead of in 100 or instead
of in a trillion steps.
It's gotten better.
>> Yeah, that's uh that's a lot of steps.
There was a major ren. There was a major
obs bug.
Okay. So,
we wire this thing. We test this in the
meantime, actually. So, I'm not just
staring at this.
I want to try something.
So, let's try inferno. Let's try async
to one.
And
oops.
>> Is that faster or No,
>> it's not. I don't think. Is it meant to
be?
>> That's weird.
77.
>> So, which bottleneck does that is that
meant to solve? Some kind of
>> That is meant to solve the N not
spinning the GPU while the uh the ENV is
going. Okay, let's just set some like
relatively more
>> let's set like what the sane parameters
would be if this end were fast.
>> And I won't commit these obviously
because this won't learn as well
probably. But
it's just total agents can be like
six
or
1 1.4 mil
1.1 to 1.4 mil.
>> See, so it is possible to have this end
to be faster.
>> But where does this come from now?
>> Comes from a few places. So first of all
show you
first of all I increase the number of
buffers.
>> Yeah.
>> So this allows you to overlap the
environment compute with the GPU work of
rollouts.
This basically splits it up into four
different CUDA streams with,024 agents
each. And then each of those CUDA
streams will sequentially run their
block of ends and run the inference.
But since they're multiple streams,
right, you could have two of those
running the end on CPU while another two
of those blocks are running inference.
And they just do that as quickly as they
can. Um, and then over here,
replay rate. This is one sample reuse a
bigger mini batch size and the whole
training is asynchronous with
evaluation.
So whether or not this is going to be
the actual you know something like this
will look like the config that solves I
don't know but I would expect that you
probably now will at least if you rewep
you'd find a config that's above 500k
provided that you have async on and that
you're having like a reasonable like end
settings.
Yeah, that's wild.
>> Yeah, this is I do a lot of
infrastructure work to make things fast,
man. This is kind of what I do.
>> Yeah, I'm kind of aggressive now to
those like
>> 100 200k SPS speed each.
>> Yeah, just immediately over a mill.
>> Now, again, these aren't super realistic
settings, but like here, let's say I
crank this to two sample reuse even. And
this is not a terrible mini batch size.
The 16
384. Maybe we'll do something like this.
It should still be much faster than
before.
Yeah. Still 500k to 800k. And uh the
fact that it's ticking back and forth
between these is kind of weird.
But yeah, still way faster. You see,
>> I gave you the CLI syntax currently for
the evol.
>> The what?
>> The current syntax in the CLI for the
evol.
>> The eval syntax
>> if you want to play the play the answer.
>> Oh, you gave me the syntax.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it's in the show. Headless
is without rendering, isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> So, we wanted to render it though.
>> Oh, yeah. Let's see if we can figure
that out.
might you might have to audit this crazy
diff,
>> but we'll see if this works
>> cuz I really what I want is, you know,
um I don't want to have the Runescape MS
have to have a different usage path from
other stuff, you know,
>> I've had people do this in the past and
it just makes things really annoying to
maintain. pain and people don't use the
ends. What I really want to do is if I
can just get the uh Runescape end usage
path to be the same as everything else,
then it just immediately becomes easier
to use it as a baseline. And I think it
should not be hard either because you've
built it correctly. It's just not like
hooked up.
>> Yeah, imagine it's
pretty easy.
It's the assets and everything that's a
bit annoying with this, I think, but
especially if you want to cook up your
like your own environment or whatever.
It's it's a bit complex for now, but
>> Mhm.
I mean, I do sort of wonder at what
point it makes sense to just like be
able to have the whole damn game world.
>> Yeah, I daydream about that, but it's
just so much work. I don't really know
how to get started with it.
It would also you wouldn't run it the
same way as they run their servers. I'm
pretty sure the NPCs just always wander
around and they always update everything
every single tick. Like you'd only want
to load stuff when a player's in the
area.
>> Yeah, now that I think about it, there's
probably some some reason why they still
have the world's cap to like 2,000
people. Yes, it's built that way.
>> It would be like way higher, but
>> yeah,
>> it's deep in the engine.
>> They just have 25 years of tech debt.
>> Yeah.
No. Well, for what it is, the game
engine is great. You know,
>> no complaints about it.
>> Being able to do this with that age tech
is just very impressive. Well, this was
if you read my thesis, this was
literally the whole inspiration for my
uh my PhD thesis, right? It was like,
hey,
>> we what do you need for RL? You need a
really fast sim with a bunch of agents,
a bunch of players like that scales
really well. Who had already built one
of those on '90s hardware? Oh, the MMO
companies. Yeah, right.
>> It was really that simple.
Uh, I don't know what this thing is
doing.
Uh, let's see if Ko runs.
>> Yeah, Colo is an even harder problem
than Inferno.
>> Is it really? I would think it would be
easier once you get the ops correct.
Yeah, may maybe that's the case, but
then it's just like the sim is so much
more complex and I don't have any
references, so like I'm flying blind on
it kind of.
>> It also depends on gear.
>> Paulo only took me Paulo took me like a
day and a half after I came back from
not having played for three years and
had only played for like a week or two.
So like Ko was not but then I also kind
of cheesed it.
Yeah,
>> this works.
>> I think I've also done it in like
Justice or whatever.
>> I just used um like the path plugin or
whatever to see what will happen if I
run south or like run to other pillar or
whatever.
>> Yeah.
No, but it's not terribly hard if you
have the basic like clicking and all
that stuff down, which you already learn
in Inferno, but the policies that we put
in in Coliseum, they haven't played
Inferno. So, it's like
>> the cycles are kind of weird sometimes.
Uh
>> yeah, I guess if you get a double south,
you're a bit like But
>> these policies don't really care about
the pillars anyway. So it's or they kind
of do like once you get this running,
you you'll notice it's it's interesting.
They they use the pillars, but not in
the way that we would. It's like
>> they use them a lot more like liberally
or like casually.
And Ko is actually just mechanically
not as bad.
I guess there are a few annoying things
like the
like if you're flicking
jab and like having the jave specs and
stuff. There are a few weird things with
Ko.
>> Well, it's more punishing I think for
mistakes.
>> In Inferno, you can really like only the
major can kill you. Yeah,
>> everything else you can just whatever
>> eat through. I suppose in column you can
really like if you
>> also don't have supplies like it's way
longer as well in Ko you can just use
your supplies and not care.
>> Yeah,
which is why I don't give it supplies.
>> You don't give it any
>> one pretty much something like that.
>> That's funny.
>> Yeah, but it has the blood fury. I just
wanted I just wanted to right away just
do like the max efficiency stuff because
uh
>> I think the the speedrunners don't bring
any brew do they
>> bring a couple I think but that's even
that's like for
skipping stuff I suppose
>> it's like it's a time save to sometimes
take damage that you eat through instead
of like having to SGS or like blood fury
or whatever because that would be So,
we're down to like 13 some minutes, I
think, for the world record on Colossio,
which is pretty wild. I think my flare
was like
>> Well, if you can train it in 13 minutes,
that would be pretty cool.
>> Yeah, that would be that would be great.
Same with
>> this will go faster as well once I turn
on async.
>> Um,
this is a smaller model.
>> It didn't. Oh.
>> Black screen.
It opened a window, but black screen.
It actually is getting to soul a few
times already after four minutes.
Yeah.
Or is this curriculum well?
>> No, it's on the real starts.
>> Oh, okay. So, it actually is getting
That's cool.
>> It is. Yeah.
>> Does this have um the invocations or
whatever they're called?
>> It does. Yeah. Yeah, that's the most
complex part about this
>> having to program all of those.
>> Yeah, there's so many different
combinations like permutations.
>> Does it actually select or is it like
scripted? What invoc?
>> Yeah, I have it in the actions.
>> That's cool.
>> And observation as well understands all
of it. They might not all be fully
perfect because it's, you know, just a
[ __ ] ton of work to get them.
>> I wonder if it knows does it know to
never pick bees or whatever already. It
doesn't really care about bees, which is
interesting. Like, it's just kind of
picks bees. And it even picks like
something like bees and red flag
together, which is just ludicrous. Like,
it would never do that.
>> I guess it just doesn't care because it
can go flick.
>> Yeah. And like kite everything around.
And it really just doesn't care about
bees at all, I've noticed.
>> And then I guess it just dies to like
not like just having some [ __ ] seem
ticked and not knowing what to do.
>> Yes, exactly. Typically, it's manticor
and uh the javelin colosa that it dies
to.
>> And then soul, I suppose soul is just
like the AoE stuff is a bit hard to get
a grass buff initially.
>> Soul I would really think it should just
instantly learn with good OBS.
>> Yeah,
soul is kind of like it kind of holds
holds your hand through the fight. It
kind of progresses in a in a nice like
understandable fashion. the fines.
>> Scrash here. Uh, Scar here actually has
a very good question which is like how
would it how would it play if it could
misclick the prayer? I actually think
that is how eventually we will get it to
do some safer strats is like give it a
small chance to misclick prayer.
>> Yeah, months ago you already gave that
suggestion and I tried it and it
definitely
>> ends up using the pillars more. This was
in inferno by the way. So it uses the
pillars more, but then I think like add
that when I was so early in the
>> in the RL that it was like the
bottlenecks were completely elsewhere.
>> I would definitely be interested in
testing it now.
>> It's winning.
>> Yeah,
>> few wins.
>> Oh, that's great. I I think this config
got like eight% on my machine. Something
like that.
But it's impressive. I've I've tried to
do some kind of analysis like if it's
struggles with certain modifiers, for
example, like if the winds tend to have
certain modifiers and whatnot, but like
it's they're kind of obvious
like volatility and uh frailty and
things of that nature that we would also
always pick.
less than one.
>> There's some weird
system crap.
>> Yeah, this is
>> too much on stack. Maybe
>> I have no idea what this is about.
Weird. Very weird.
Let's see how Ko's doing.
>> Yeah,
>> I also
in my mind this type of a curve is
pretty weird to me.
Like typically once you get any signal
you should just be giga insta solving
and the fact that it isn't tells me that
like there's probably some stuff where
it's getting red effectively because
there's something that it can't see. So
it has to take like an inconsistent
strat and get lucky
because very very often like when we
have these problems that are like 0000
as soon as you get some signal all the
way to the end it just insta solves.
Puffer is really good at that.
>> Yeah.
>> So, the some of the advice I gave Finn,
which I don't know how easy it is in
your case, but for Net Hack, I told him
like, "Hey, why don't you set it up in a
room and like see what it logits and
value is, right? And then go put go put
a wand of digging three tiles away. Does
that like does it care?" Okay. Well, you
have like a patch encoder and a global
encoder. What happens if you put it
outside of the local encoder for the and
like inside of the global encoder range?
Does it know then? Like you can
basically construct a lot of different
things where there's a thing where you
know it should be able to see and care.
>> And if it's not learning that
>> then you can kind of sus out why uh like
what it can't see correctly.
>> Yeah, for sure. And there's been so many
of those
>> things I fixed over the over the months.
>> I also do wonder with the switches like
>> can it only switch one item per tick?
No, it can switch any any amount all of
the slots if it wants to.
>> Sometimes it does.
>> Just click everything.
>> Yeah. Yeah, but it can only select one
of each slot. So, you know, it can't
equip two helms, for example.
But yeah, I've had plenty of these like
occasions where something is kind of
like poisoning the entire entire
training process be like soul firing
some attacks like maybe in a in a manner
where it's like not really possible to
predict them or whatnot. And of course I
can play the sim myself, but then it's
it's almost impossible to play all the
modifier combinations, for example,
together. So like I know that there's
this bound to be this tiny bugs here and
there, but it's just kind of like needle
in a hay stack problem.
>> There's I mean depending on how much
stuff you want to do with it, right?
Like there's really cool debug things
you can do like you can map observations
in the env
that that it sees you can map like the
waiting that it's assigning to that on
the input layer. Uh,
and you can like paint that in the
environment so it can actually see how
much it's paying attention to each
thing.
>> Like there are all sorts of things that
you can do. I had this in my old neural
MMO where the agents would wander around
and you could enable this overlay that
would show exactly like from their
perspective what was important around
them.
>> It doesn't move the cursor at all.
And I don't think that's a like
practical thing. Like any decent player
can move can click anything on their
screen in one tick.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean, in the end it
has to be something that obvious because
>> Mhm.
>> Well, the problem is pretty well defined
ultimately like in the real game, but
then just the simulator is the hard
part. So,
I don't know. And now it's at that point
where it's just watching it play is not
enough. It kind of like it plays
plausibly and it like does the correct
stuff but then it just like dies.
>> This is the same conversation I had with
Finn um yesterday with the mechan stuff.
Can't switch all Yeah. So that we should
we basically we would have to put a cap
on the number of things per tick.
>> Yeah. I've done I've done that in PvP
for example. wanted to make it plausible
because if I don't set any like limit on
actions then it just you know does
everything every tick which is why
wouldn't it
>> it can
>> probably should be something like four
>> yeah I think the way I did it and which
ended up working really well actually
was like I think maybe I gave it three
kind of for free and then I started
applying for each one a tiny penalty so
it ended up really just doing the
correct thing with like three or four
switches everything or actions,
prayers included as well. So
>> yeah, I know I can do
I can probably do about four actions per
tick on average. Any more than that is
>> it it actually it's a very hard fall
off.
>> Yeah. On on average is pushing it even
because like you can definitely
>> probably between three and four.
>> Yeah. And that doesn't mean I'm doing
three or four actions every tick. It
means like if I'm trying to do a bunch
of stuff all at once.
>> Like typically
>> it'll be three or four actions per tick.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I think I can manage about the
same. And I I don't think it really like
even the very top top guys I don't think
they can really do much more than that.
Like it could be their average is one
higher than ours but like
>> Oh no. The one the guys that are really
good, they can do seven ways.
>> Yeah. Yeah, they can. But like then it's
like you see in some like YouTube clip,
I don't know if they can do it like back
and forth six times in a row, for
example. Like
>> it genuinely is pretty like you still
have to use the cursor and like it's
like pretty pretty slow to switch stuff
around in this game. So
>> I will say that like a lot of the stuff
that inventory layout doesn't matter as
much anymore because look, you can do
this now. This is allowed.
>> Yeah,
>> I like as soon as I this was allowed, I
moved my prayers like this. And now you
don't have to put gear down here or
anything. And you can even do it with
spells. Like you can move
>> I should even move venge, but like you
can move whatever.
>> And now do you use spec from the orb?
>> Uh I do, but I don't really PvP.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah.
>> I like I do a little bit for fun, but I
I'm not that good.
Yeah,
>> you can orb spec though and it works the
same as the spec bar.
>> Yeah, I guess nowadays you can in PVP.
They changed it maybe not that long ago.
>> It's still slightly better to do um spec
bar because it's right on top of each
other, but it's
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's still slightly better, but
it's more annoying because then you have
to move everything to the bottom.
Yeah. Yeah. That's pretty much how
you're forced to play if you want to be
serious about NH.
>> Um,
>> you have the
>> I would think more for revenge PK it
matters, right? For NH it's not as big.
>> Uh, well, yeah, maybe. I don't I don't
really
>> But even then, like you can still one
tick with orbit. So, it's like one tick
is one tick.
>> Yeah. Yeah, really it's just the just
the spec that matters because everything
else like you said you can move around.
>> Yeah.
Oh. Uh
okay. Yeah. So, there's something
there's definitely something weird going
on with uh the stack size. Probably
there's just too much stuff on it.
Does this work now?
Why do we have black screen, man?
No idea.
>> I've got a
655.
>> Yeah. I want to check that. Let me see.
What is this about?
>> Okay, we get 10% win rate
>> on call.
>> 10%.
>> On call. And now this is 549. Let me see
how fast I can get this to go. Oh, there
it is. It fixed it.
Look at this.
>> Oh, boom.
>> It's very slow though, isn't it? No,
>> it's teleporting a bunch. I think it's
just mixing rollouts up. Hang on.
Yeah, just it wasn't playing at the
native speed
Runescape and Net Hack are going to be
two very, very important M. And I also
have somebody working on Craftex
um which is like mini Net Hack in a way.
That should be uh that should be about
like 5x faster than Net Hack or um
Runescape. And that should be like a
nice intermediate stepping stone
here. Let me do this for you. Oh, also
these need perf stats on them. Uh, which
should just be the equal to the win
rate, I would imagine.
>> I can also mess with that. That's fine.
All right, let's see how fast I can
magically make this.
You actually have 32 threads on this
one.
Yeah, this was so
kind of weird train arg But
the replay ratio
has no mini batch size.
>> Oh, look at that. 1.4 mil SPS. 1.5 mil
SPS.
So yeah, both your M's can get above a
mill.
No idea whether it'll learn anything in
these params, but it can get above a
mill.
[ __ ] spilled my coke everywhere.
What were you saying?
>> Hollow is at 1.3 mil average.
Okay. And this is with async and more
reasonable config.
>> I think more realistically you're
probably going to sweep this to
somewhere around 800k for both of these
cuz this is like replay ratio one and
whatever.
But this is still like async should get
you quite a bit here. It's this exact
>> if it maintains learnability to even
close to the same extent. It's not
>> async is always async is never once you
retune async is never a big hit. It's
pretty much always worth it to do async.
>> Yeah,
>> I mean I have soda on everything with
it.
>> It's going to triple my duration speed
if that's if that helps. But yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> It would be cool.
Yeah. This is why I spend so much time
right on all the info.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, it does work surprisingly often,
doesn't it? Just going fast.
>> Mhm.
I mean, it's doing some stuff, but
obviously this is not going to be a good
config with what I just set up.
>> Yeah, in my experience, wave three is
around the kind of like random zone.
>> It gets to wave three randomly.
>> Why? not not fully randomly but I mean
the type of like you know whatever naive
kind of baseline or whatever can get
there. So
>> I do think that Grock throttles you or
something every so often.
Yeah. I don't know what's going on with
the wall here. Maybe it's just been
broken. I haven't noticed on the
>> Mhm.
>> stand alone.
I also have I still have the annoying
issue of like having a MacBook that I
view all the visual stuff on.
>> Yeah. So we definitely you have we do
have it at least now. So the CPU render
just works, right?
>> Um but that does mean you can't test the
GPU render cleanly.
>> Yeah.
>> Also, no big deal. I don't mind doing
some integration for an end that's this
awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> But the real question is, do you think
it can defeat the gem crab?
>> Yeah. Well, I don't know. It's It's a
tough boss if you want to kill it, you
know. It's It keeps escaping from you.
>> Yeah. You just You always hit it. It's
more players hit that than any other
boss and it never dies.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Must be confusing to new new
players coming from other MMOs, you
know?
>> Yeah. Like
>> never dies. I really like the story of
that one though where they just like
every update they just kept adding crabs
to every new piece of terrain so that
people would have a training spot and
then they finally got sick of it and
just added one really big crab.
>> Yeah,
>> they do have a sense of humor. It's
great.
>> That's like my favorite story from that
from the game of like just the dev of
it. It's like oh yeah, there were rock
crabs and then there were sand crabs and
ammonite crabs and swamp crabs.
Eventually, it just won a really big
crab.
>> Yeah. And it's like it feels like pretty
much nobody else is able to do stuff
like this other than like the Runescape
devs.
>> Yeah.
>> You've got this like battle pass
Fortnite type ADHD games nowadays. And
it's just it feels like that's
everything that exists
>> other than Runescape.
>> Yeah.
All right. That's good.
or maybe where it's just old. I don't
know.
>> Yeah, I get I get annoyed even I was
getting uh I was really annoyed even
about like the chambers drop rate buffs
and uh then I got I this I'm not even
joking. I got three megas in 10 raids.
>> Yeah,
>> after the changes.
>> 10 raids is what you said. Literally
Kodi Kodi elder in 10 raids.
>> Oh yeah yeah yeah.
>> It's like one I looked up the odds of
that. It's like one in 92,000.
>> Well
>> Well, you're never going to see one
again. So
>> well the unfortunate thing is any of
those could have been TBO, right?
>> Yeah. True.
Yeah. Yeah, I really just rather get a
Dex than a than a Kodan, but
>> Kodan's still 50 mil.
>> Yeah,
>> all right. Why is this frozen?
Something is real jank here. I don't
know what
>> Okay, this is now
>> this is now running like through GDB or
something. So, it's smooth, but it's
laggy.
Yeah,
I have the hott key to speed it up or
slow it down on like number key nine and
zero, I suppose. But it doesn't look
like this is this is it.
This is just junk. Yeah. So, it's
speeding up, but it like it's still
slow.
>> Yeah,
it teleports.
very simil Yeah,
and it's a very good. It just need
There's some jank that we just need to
fix with the merge.
That's going to be so much fun though to
just like
mess with.
Yeah, it would benefit from some kind of
like I have this kind of like lab thing
that I already showed briefly where you
can just like mobs anywhere.
>> One thing you might want to do on a lot
of the code, by the way,
>> this is so incredibly stupid,
>> but this actually kind of works.
Have you seen this file?
>> Oh, where is it?
>> Oh. Oh yeah, I I saw it on stream one
day.
>> I it this actually kind of works.
>> Yeah, like all this like this algorithm
makes sense here. So
>> I I've just run this on people's PRs and
cut a third of the code off with no loss
of anything.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Well, you can imagine how much I
have to think about this because it's
like I've been doing this dumb porting
for like god know god knows how long
with the LLMs and it's just like they
keep doing things so stupid. So
>> yeah,
>> I constantly just have to be
simplifying. It's like a loop of you
know port a whole bunch of [ __ ] and
then spend ages simplifying it.
>> This is exactly where this came from,
right? So this was from me cleaning up
code for two weeks and then eventually
it's like, all right, they do the same
stupid pattern. I get this in every PR.
It's the same stupid pattern. You just
do this and it's good.
>> Or at least it's like not awful.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It still hangs on to some
defensive stuff for sure.
>> It's hard to overcome a [ __ ] ton of, you
know, trillions of tokens of RL and
whatever [ __ ] they do. I don't know.
>> I remember at one point like years ago,
I remember seeing, have you ever heard
of the defensive semicolon?
>> No. No, Alan,
>> is people sometimes will put a semicolon
at the start of their lines of code in
case they forgot one
>> on the previous line.
>> Yeah, I've heard of this way back like
Java or something. I don't know.
>> It I don't know if it's Java or
JavaScript or what. It's just some jank
though.
>> Yeah,
>> it's just like it's fine. let the
program crash and then fix it. You're
not you're not working at NASA. You're
not writing the Mars rover. It's fine.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think two semicolons is fine in
either whatever language this was for
400 lines off robot arm with it. Yeah,
it works. Because the thing is this is
not like some prompting magic. This is
literally just me writing down what I do
when people submit me garbage code.
And like it's very easy to write code
that doesn't require you to do this.
Like if you want to know how to write
code that doesn't require you to have to
refactor [ __ ] like this. Like, okay,
inline every function that's only used
once. Very simply, don't split out
functions unless you're going to call
them twice. Eliminate defensive checks.
Don't write defensive checks. Reduce
deeply nefted code. Invert your trivial
if statements ahead of time. Co-optimize
multiconsumer. Okay, this is general
refactoring. This just kind of requires
you to think a little as you're writing.
You'll have to do a little of this. And
then syntax and style guide. Don't [ __ ]
up your syntax and style while you're
writing it.
Like that's it.
and they still do some of that stuff.
But it is what it is.
>> Yeah.
Okay. Apparently,
>> apparently there's some weird jank.
>> You can promise that it's going to work
now.
>> Oh, I can play with it a little today
though if it runs.
Why does it take this long to start up?
>> Asset loading.
>> I wouldn't think so. No.
>> Like fault.
>> It also hasn't taken this long at all in
my
test. So
But apparently this is non-trivial. Like
my LLM has been going at this for I
don't know how long now. How long?
>> Well, it's just because there's a big
mess of code, right?
>> Yeah.
Yeah, but this is the kind of [ __ ] that
I I just create this like divergence.
It's like Mac versus UDA is so different
when it comes to some of the stuff and
it's just end up
>> but like it's running this render just
fine.
>> I don't know.
Oh,
>> it seems to be doing the
somewhat correct thing here as well. So,
this is definitely the
>> Wait, what cape do you have this thing
we're using?
>> What cape?
>> Wait, what? Oh, quiver. Okay,
>> quiver.
>> Yeah, I I didn't see cuz I saw the back
of the verdice robe.
>> I I still forget those are in the game.
I still don't even have verdice.
It's like I have ancestral and I did
just recently get conflictions.
>> I'm in shadow rebuild at the moment. So
I have
>> Do you have all three megas?
>> No, not even close.
>> Okay.
>> I I think I'm like 2.1 bill or
something.
>> I have scythe bow and
everything but oath plate and shadow
pretty much.
>> Yeah, that's nice.
With two megas, you can already kind of
do everything
>> mostly. Yeah.
>> The third one is more so like quality of
life, I think. But
>> honestly, like with eye of shadow,
unless you camp Toa is not as needed.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Toa would be the only place where
you kind of want Shadow, but
>> Oh, it's really good there. But like
then you have to do Toa.
Yeah, it almost sucks. It's terrible. I
hate it.
>> I It was like so cool on release and
then everybody kind of realized it was
awful.
>> Yeah. I don't know who figured it would
be a good idea to make the puzzles like
repeatable.
>> I It's also just the scaling, man. Like
the fact that you have to crank it up
super high and like if you like since
everybody sweats and farms that then
everybody has to sweat and farm that.
>> Oh yeah, it's true. Like it was supposed
to be balanced for um like 300s,
right? But then 300s are literally worse
money than Vorcath
like it's awful.
>> That's true. The scaling isn't super
like satisfying. I don't think if you're
on 500s like everything has a [ __ ] ton
of health
>> and one shots you.
>> Yeah, exactly. Like the mechanics are
pretty fun. Like I I like the modifiers
are invos for the most part because of
like they make the fights more
interesting in a sense, but like they
have a [ __ ] ton of scaling slapped on
top of it. It feels like that old like
video game where you have just like
everything starts one-shotting you
like takes a ton of time to kill.
>> It's weird because I don't mind the
chambers puzzle rooms at all, but I hate
the Toa ones.
>> Yeah, same here. Actually, I don't I
don't know what that's about. Maybe it's
the tall ones are just so trivial and so
stupid.
>> Well, it also feels like Chambers is
much more like you chill up until and
then you like not screw up, right?
>> Yeah.
>> It's got like a nice cadence to it.
>> Yeah, true. I like I like Cox. Don't
click that.
I was just about to say
like uh Yeah, Chambers.
>> Chambers. Yeah.
>> No, but Tobi is definitely by far the
best.
>> Well, it's funny cuz that one it doesn't
have the puzzles. It's like you have to
pay attention the whole time, but there
are no puzzles. That works.
>> And even though it's repetitive, it's
like it just doesn't matter at all. Like
it's always fun to me. I do think though
that the um
>> I do think it's incredibly bad the way
that they've balanced the drop rates
that all the profit from all three raids
is in the mega.
>> Yeah,
it's definitely like it doesn't feel
great as a player, but like I don't know
>> if there's an alternative really.
>> You just make you just make the drops
rarer and they hold value.
>> Yeah. I mean, why is Kibo hold, right?
It's because like for every person
raiding, less than one Tibo comes into
the game. So, go more people want it
than there are of them.
>> Yeah, but they're going to have to
balance that as well because like if
they make the drop super rare, then it's
not rewarding
or I I guess it would be, but like it
would burn people out quicker or
something like that. Definitely, they
have to think about it.
>> I don't know. Like I I I don't like the
fact that there are like complete trash
drops in these raids. Like you
>> No. Well, they're trash cuz they're so
common, right? They're actually useful,
but they're so common.
>> Yeah.
>> Like before they made all the changes to
the prayer scroll drop rates, um decks
and uh decks actually held value.
>> Yeah.
>> Before they made it more common. And
like I think once a vernick got to be
super cheap, like Tob was literally
you're there for scythe or nothing.
Yeah, that's how it is.
>> I don't know.
It's definitely feels bad though that
like that you have other than the megas,
the average profit is way way worse than
even like relatively chill simple mid
game bosses.
>> Yeah, it doesn't feel good.
>> Mhm.
>> I've never even got a sight. I think
I've had like 300 top.
>> I've about the same. I think I've seen
one side split.
>> Yeah.
I do think one of the things that you
have to do for balance is you kind of
have to speed limit players. Um, like
there have to be certain things that
just take a fixed amount of time every
raid because otherwise if you have the
top players doing it so so so much
faster, it just they bring so many drops
into the game that like they crash the
prices super fast.
Yeah, I guess that's
>> like the thing is if if they can only do
the raid like 20% faster than your
average player, they'll go do some other
piece of content that they can do three
times faster
>> and then the prices don't get totally
crashed.
>> Yeah, I've been getting split on this
throughout my kind of like gaming
career, I suppose, because I I've always
been the type who just like pushes end
game like records and everything. just
like plays for the end game only
>> and the most challenging. I guess now
it's started to shift a bit because you
know I'm a dad and no longer have time
to play as much.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm getting those like Yeah. Maybe
maybe give some drops to the rest of us
as well. I don't know.
>> But it's definitely like to a nice
example that like
>> the thing is by by doing that they're
worth nothing, right? Like there's no
money.
>> The best ring in the game's worth 4 mil.
It would make a ton of sense that if you
if you run to with like eight people and
you get maybe you run like max in of 600
or something like that. I I I think
according to the maths right now it's
the reward chance or purple chance is
still like 30% or something like that
>> for that setup which is just like
ludicrous. Like the amount of effort
that takes is like you'd expect to get
rewarded every raid more or less and
then you have eight people to split it
with. So, I don't know. Some of that
just like they haven't thought about all
of it.
>> I don't understand how it segs every
time.
>> I was looking invisibility into what's
going on there.
>> I genuinely don't understand what the
heck is going on here.
>> Yeah.
>> Now it doesn't even pull up the window.
>> Yeah, it's running some other thing.
And let's hang on. Let me just double
check that we didn't drop Nvidia SMI.
I I don't think we did.
No.
Yeah. I don't know what the heck.
>> It was 380 on this machine.
>> That Well, this is my local machine.
>> Shouldn't matter.
>> Those are probably both Runescape
Windows.
>> Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Speaking of, I've been
standing here. I need to get my fire
making again.
>> Did you already do fishing?
No, I had an idea for that though.
>> Yeah, I just did a fishing today and
it's kind of chill actually now. Like
you still can do it for hours on end,
but like I don't mind an hour now. It's
great speed.
>> Um there have you seen the the sailing
boosting thing?
>> Sailing boosting thing.
>> Yeah. So you can actually you can get
like 10 people on a boat with one person
steering it and they can just AFK for 10
minutes and get sailing and fishing XP.
>> Oh, interesting. And you're going to pay
somebody for that?
>> Well, what you do is you just deposit
all the fish that you catch. And because
they have 10 people, they make 15 mil an
hour.
>> Okay.
>> Which is pretty funny.
>> No, I haven't heard of that at all.
>> Yeah. It's not super fast, but it's both
skills.
>> Yeah. Are you AFK for 10 minutes? Is
that
>> I think it's like 10 minutes. Yeah. They
get mad if you if you miss one though
cuz then you stop catching fish or
whatever. But
>> I think it has a pretty high wreck, like
92 sailing or something. But it's still
>> pretty funny.
>> I have not done fishing. Fishing is 91.
>> Almost 92.
>> Are you maximal sailing?
No, no, no. 72 was the lowest kill
there.
>> Oh, yeah. Same for me.
>> And bothered.
>> Yeah, I didn't even do the last trial.
Yeah,
>> I have 600k mining XP saved because I
need Dale essence for 99 RC.
>> Oh, yeah. No,
>> you're saving the best for last.
Uh RC is not actually that bad anymore.
Agility is absolutely just getting like
AFK, Bluetooth mouse clicked.
>> Yeah, I actually like both skills. I
like RC and Agel both of them.
>> You might be a bit of a massochist.
>> Yeah, I don't know.
And I'm just I don't know if I'm like a
contrarian, but like I I don't really
like Slayer at all, for example. It's
just
>> I don't know that skills awful.
>> Yeah.
Well, I think construction is
>> I mean most like a lot of them should
just be a lot of these should have been
combined or like actually do something.
I would love it if you could like level
that up by actually building some kind
of cool house, you know, for yourself.
>> I like
>> Yeah, but then it would be way too fast.
It's It's like a lot of them weren't
thought out.
>> Yeah. And they would be massively
complex if they wanted to like spread it
out a bit. But
>> I like the like ex exploration or
mapping or whatever you're doing in
sailing. Like you can
>> Yeah. But then they made that like a
tiny amount of it and then it's just sit
at a race course or AFK. It's kind of
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It would be fun if you could like
explore
>> only. But of course, that wouldn't be
possible either. So, I don't know.
But I definitely felt like I was playing
like a like a new game when I came came
back to the uh game and I was just like
going through sailing for the first
time.
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, when I got back um
like Ko and Doom and other stuff were
out.
Have you done doing already now?
>> Uh, I've done quite a bit of it. I have
not gotten all achieves yet.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, I think last time I heard you
hadn't even tried it yet.
>> Uh,
>> I think it's the best.
>> The 16
depth is annoying but doable. The
perfect one is going to be really
annoying and the speedrun's really
annoying.
Yeah, perfect thing is kind of like it's
so so easy to mess up one thing like
step on one poison basically is how
you're always failing.
>> Oh, but it's a fun boss and Yama as
well. I think it's pretty fun. So,
>> I've only done a few Yama. I didn't I
haven't done it enough to actually know
if I like that boss.
>> Yeah,
>> it is a duo boss, which is cool.
I haven't really done a duo with some
randoms on it at times, but not like
serious coordinated
>> straight like easier and whatever duo,
isn't it?
>> Yeah, it's just faster. It's the same
boss, but it's two people killing it.
Mhm.
>> Just loot the loot.
>> I do think that they should try to make
sure that the um the duo bosses are like
equal or better loot in duo rather than
trying to like make it oh it's actually
better of solo.
>> Yeah, that would be rewarding. I would
feel
>> like I remember everybody hated Nex. I
actually didn't mind nex
um cuz it was like really good in
>> like you didn't need to try to do a duo
or whatever. It was good in small teams.
Oh, hey Jess. Uh yeah, I missed your
messages. So, we're just chilling at the
moment trying to figure out what the
heck is wrong with the rendering here.
Uh both of the M's, Ko and Inferno, run.
The policies are getting wins on both of
them, though not at a great rate yet. We
discussed some decoder changes
uh that probably can get yoked from the
net hack branch or the net hack file at
least.
And we're basically just dealing with
some integration crap. Trying to figure
out what the hell's wrong.
Not really. I I just genuinely don't. Am
I using the wrong bin file or something?
>> That wouldn't make sense, would it?
>> No.
>> Yeah. Just load anyway.
I'm verifying that my fix works. I'll
see if this
ends up rendering. Of course, I can't
super directly test it, but it's like a
small kit on the
I'm not a big fan of the fact that now
by default they just hide all of these
tool calls and even the reasoning traces
and whatnot. It's like they're
constantly pushing the UX towards the
direction where you just like prompt and
then don't even look at the thing.
>> Yeah,
it's very dumb.
Yeah. So, look at this. It's
>> I just saw it in the tray say that it
was running U limit before.
>> So, it's it's a stack limit thing, I'm
pretty sure.
>> No,
>> Mesa.
Yeah. See, it just like it ran a test
with a different command and then said,
"Oh, I'm doing the exact same command
except for this, this, and this."
>> Yeah.
>> Like
seriously.
>> Um, colo. Okay, so this would be five
minute colo. Obviously, this doesn't do
particularly well. This is only wave
4.2.
Um, has to be retuned, but
that's pretty good.
>> Yeah, definitely. And that's a smaller
model as well. It's 700k per.
>> Yeah, it'll get auto retuned. Um,
actually, we can
>> we have this nice graph, don't we?
We can literally just put like flops
versus uh
I also can't think of why this would be
messed up. Like this works for every
other end. I presume some just something
very dumb is being done in a wrong order
or something and it can't tell because
there's just like a billion lines of
everything.
>> Oh yeah, it could be.
Oh yeah, my island's just been spinning
evil in place here for 10 minutes or
something in a tool call that I couldn't
see. So, you know, it's just been stuck.
>> Well, they do have um
Does this make it think harder or does
this show you the race?
>> It kind of tries to show you more of it,
but then it still sucks. So, I'm not
really sure what they did there, but
like let's be honest, I don't really
care all that much about the reasoning
traders. Like, I would rather just see
the
just see a line of what is actually
doing.
>> That's fair.
because the only thing that reading the
LLM speak is going to do is going to
make you dumber as well. So, let's just
It just like tries to like ah yes let me
now make a mess.
>> Yeah.
>> Like ah I see you have a problem. Let me
make you five more problems.
>> Yeah. And it just be so confident about
it as well.
>> Oops. I spun 500k token. Now I'm going
to compress and forget the problem.
Yeah,
>> it's totally AGI, by the way, folks.
It's going to do everything.
>> Quick fix, revert the whatever.
>> Quick fix, revert everything.
>> Yeah, he's going to fix it real quick.
It's changing core,
removing something. Is this stuff they
added in the first place or
>> possibly?
Oh, yeah. That's a totally good render,
my guy. Nice job.
Max is going to say, "Well, Pong
actually works perfectly fine.
Why doesn't inferno
like the thing is this is why I hate
having just giant ass projects because
it's like I'm sure it's some basic init
but I have no idea where to even look.
Yeah,
>> I I do think at some point we should
just like compact and compact and
compact and see how short we can get the
Runescape code. It's probably still
going to be
>> a lot.
>> Yeah, I've done it a lot to be fair, but
it's
>> Yeah, it just like there's no way around
it. It's like you're going to have tens
and tens of thousands of lines of code
in this game. It's like,
>> yeah,
removing the ob obvious junk is it's a
good use of time, but then reading,
>> have you done stuff like just like map
out how much code is devoted to each
major game feature or section and just
sanity check? Like, does that seem like
the right amount of code?
>> Yeah, I've done it a bunch and
especially so when I move stuff into the
shared headers from the from the outers
themselves.
And always I end up losing quite a bit
of lines of code. But then I compared to
these like efficient implementations
where I have tons of references but it's
always a bit iffy. Then like even in the
references you have disagreements and
just
not that great of a time.
>> Mhm.
But at least though it's like fairly
easily verifiable like we can we can
tell quite quickly if something's just
straight up wrong or doesn't feel like
Runescape. So at least it's generous in
that sense. Mhm.
>> problem.
But yeah, really like 95% of my
attention of course goes to this like
very core fundamentals be like path
finding or uh like damage calculations
and then of course the RL itself. So it
could be there there's so many different
like tiny things hiding in the massive
amount of
>> path finding is so weird to me that they
like
the player does complicated pathf
finding right but then the um
>> Yeah. Now they've even started like
introducing
>> the smart mobs with
>> museum and all that.
>> They've started playing around with
different types of path finding and
>> I believe they're now even like
even changing the newer NPCs to follow
that like
>> Yeah. Yeah, they are the smart path
diagonal first. I guess they do.
>> They definitely Yeah, it's the minotaur
like the red card invo.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that like even in general
like I think they're changing. It used
to be the other way around for NPCs so
that they first go in a straight line
and then in a in a diagonal or now I
don't remember which which ways for for
players, but they're trying to make it
so the NPCs basically do the same as
players to make it simpler, but
>> I don't know. Obviously, they can't just
go back and change everything, you know.
Well, it's more than that because the
players have additional path finding for
obstacles.
>> Yeah, true.
>> Yeah, we have the BSS thing.
>> Yeah,
>> this is still a mil SPS.
This is maybe a reasonable config. We'll
see. This is the type of thing you just
sweep. I kind of just left this in the
meantime.
>> What What is this What is this stupid
thing doing is my question.
We did sort of change the eval loop a
bit, I suppose.
>> Yeah,
>> probably it's just the wiring of that.
This doesn't learn great. This is just
going to need a new
>> sweep.
Fixing these two M's. I mean, it's
mostly just the render
and then reweep on new configs. I think
>> there is still the decoder thing. Um,
and that's that's more of an
optimization though. Uh, and we'll
basically just be able to test that
immediately on the win rate
outcome.
I actually I'm pretty confident that if
we just get these things rendering
cleanly and it just doesn't feel jank,
like I can probably even just autoport
that decoder in.
And you should probably see immediately
a big performance improvement.
>> Well, if it's anything close to the
encoder, then yeah, it would be it would
be nice.
>> Oh, yeah, it is. encoder was immediate I
think like plus two average wave or
something silly like that in my
>> contwise
like
literally even the uh so this minimal
end I
>> do a combination of things right in
research I like to have these big hard
ends that we want to solve but then also
we have these very easy synthetic
environments
um that you can test specific things
with. So this end you can't solve
without the entity encoder.
Something this simple
already you can't just solve without
entity encoder.
>> It's literally just go to
the nearest
star of your color.
>> Oh yeah. And then it switches colors.
And you see they have to spread out
because they want to have them all
occupied.
>> Yeah.
>> So this does not solve without entity
encoder.
So this is where I developed the entity
encoder actually, right? Is I made a
fast thing that solves this
>> and then we tested this and it works
everywhere.
So you kind of have to have a little bit
of information about like the thing that
you're designing to not just develop
something easy that doesn't work
anywhere else even if you do solve it.
But
this things like this are very
informative for designing
fixes to specific research problems.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I guess in ours it's like
it learns the NPCs like really dumb if
you don't have the entity encoder. It
kind of memorizes the
>> like the onehole positions basically or
whatever.
>> It in my mind like it has to be
well yeah let's let's play the game like
this blind. That sounds great.
It's funny seeing them struggle with the
assets the same way that I did when I
got started
with the infernal cape being all messed
up and everything.
>> It also they their logic is not correct
here.
regarding what
>> uh the if the way that I'm going here,
it would follow me cuz I'm one tick
late.
>> Are you though?
>> Yeah, I'm oneick.
>> Are you sure?
>> Yeah.
>> Looks good to me. No,
>> he would follow if I don't go back on
same tick. I'm pretty sure.
Like you see how I'm delayed to take
here now. He He still doesn't go back.
>> Yeah, there I'm good on not getting hit.
The inventory just kind of sucks.
>> Yeah. Not being back against the wall in
this fight is not a fun time.
>> Great. Why didn't Bruise drink?
Literally, Bruise didn't drink.
>> Well,
>> definitely a great boss fight this as
well, by the way.
>> Yeah, it should learn this instantly,
though. Like,
>> yeah,
it mostly seems to be struggling with
the environmental damage here, the like
the lava or whatever. and the lasers.
>> It has to be able to see that though.
Like
>> yeah,
>> it's
>> Yeah, I've got the OS nicely laid out. I
think it's just a matter of like
learning like it's just something's
holding back
holding back from learning, you know,
somewhere else. I think it just gets
confused about something else. it can be
that like if I put it only in soul it
just kind of like immediately solves it
to like 90% plus and it's almost like it
doesn't really matter what the config is
either. So it's immediately after I um
introduce the waves that it gets a bit
more confusing but even wave 11 is very
hard compared to just solve
Can you try pulling um PR 656?
>> Did you fix it?
>> Yeah, it should fix it. Let's see.
>> Yeah, let me just make sure that this
thing is not
completely trolling.
>> Yeah.
This is making some changes now in
offer launch.
>> Well, this is pretty much the same stuff
that Gro seems to be having.
>> I I think this thing has just made a
mess and I'm probably going to revert
this at this point. Like I don't know
what the hell dumb [ __ ] this is doing,
but
>> this is worthless. Maybe it's done
soon.
It smokes fine on the box, but like I I
can't see.
>> It keeps saying that the smokes are
fine, but it's like lying. It's setting
some extra flags and some crap or it's
running from somewhere else.
>> Um
>> cuz the thing doesn't even build
>> in the shop.
So it's just changing
We'll try this. And otherwise, I'm
reverting it because it's just been
spinning and being dumb. Pretty
eding tests.
>> Yeah, I don't know why.
>> I got to look at what has changed in
Puffarel.
>> If this is still broken though, I'm just
reverted because it's like break
everything for no reason.
>> Yeah.
Uh, I think that's fine other than being
framey.
>> Yeah, seems like it.
>> That's just frame skip though.
There's stuff in there I That doesn't
What? What is this?
>> Yeah, these warnings just make no sense.
>> No. Well, what is this? I've never seen
this.
>> What is this? I don't know what this
>> in brackets equals
>> I don't know what these values are.
>> This is like something compiling C99 as
invid as uh as CUDA but
>> array designators. Wait, this is not
even correct. Why?
Yeah,
it's bored.
How does this crash on frame one? Like
how
it's setting you limit or some [ __ ]
I'm like
here.
Can you paste the um PR link to this
bot? I think it's going to
>> Yeah.
>> Hopefully understand what the
Yeah, this is about what you would
expect.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
straight up.
>> The shim is a little weird.
the changes in puff for as well.
See what it did to
>> Well, this is [ __ ]
No, I don't really
see the point here.
Is this some kind of brute force?
What is it trying to do here?
>> It's trying to like not make all the
ends,
but it doesn't understand that they're
multi-agent ends because it's not
actually smart.
Rendered. Evil uses one agent and one
open MP thread, which is why Inferno is
blowing the stack.
Yeah,
>> it still shouldn't be blowing up the
stack.
>> Yeah,
>> it doesn't. That explanation doesn't
make sense.
It doesn't
even this is so unnecessarily slow. It's
like
>> Mhm.
>> you just have a PR here and you can
literally look copy all of it.
>> Well, I I would have mer I would merge
that, but there were a couple other
things with like
the custom models. If this breaks it, I
will just revert and merge directly and
then try to clean up. like
>> this this language model is just
thinking so much about you know
>> no
>> really have to
what it is
>> the wave four
>> yeah it's not it's not terribly good
>> no
>> I don't know if you remember the wave
layout in in column But
>> wave four
and then
>> wave four is easy.
>> Yeah, it is. Then only after like
five it really starts ramping up a bit.
Even then you have some kind of easy
ways.
In my experience when it starts getting
like past eight or something, it's
actually doing something useful before
then.
>> It gets just very spawn dependent at
some point.
Yeah.
>> I mean, you can have a free wave 10.
I see the issue now.
Yeah.
>> All right. I'm trying to think what else
we can do in the meantime. So
obviously yoinking.
Oh, you can go ahead and just try to
yink the entity decoder
on your thing in the meantime.
>> Just point it at Net Hack. Um,
>> I would think that you could just take
your same colo params and just use that
and it would work.
>> Yeah, I'll try and study it a bit so
that I know how to adapt it if I need
to.
I mean, did I It's basically the same as
I mean, this is how old this is
They have the entity encoder in here
somewhere.
Sure. I have a there's a diagram
It's a lot of pages.
>> That's a PhD thesis.
It's basically all of the papers I wrote
stapled together with um
some glue sections.
I actually only spent like a week on
this document.
>> How much of this did you have done
before even starting the program?
>> Uh good question. Let me look.
Where is the architecture?
the first paper I would say this first
major paper
and a good a good chunk of the second
paper
were from before the program.
Oh, fair.
Where's the damn thing?
>> Well, it's fair to say you had to be
interested in this stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> Beforehand as well
>> to end up where you are now.
>> Yeah.
Find the damn
Oh, yeah. Here it is. This is the before
I knew how to make decent figures.
You see this two-layer entity attribute
encoding?
Yeah.
This was like two layer attentional
architecture.
>> Here it is. This is the architecture
right here. Look at this.
So this is your entity encoder. You see
this?
>> You raw game data. So your entities,
>> you encode the entities and you have now
attribute vectors per entity
>> and then you merge these into an ent
into entity embeddings. We kind of
skipped this step in our version and we
have an more efficient single layer one.
But then you still have an attentional
feature here that combines entity
embeddings into an obsetting. So this G
would be like the the linear max
projection thing.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. But then look here on the
output. This is what I was looking for.
So you have in this case these are the
entities you're encoding into action
embeddings. This would be like ancestral
top, right? Switch ancestral top. This
is like switch treads.
>> And then you have encodings for all of
these.
Oh,
>> doing something.
>> It's still seging. Um, and then you can
see here
this is a dot product. So this Z is your
entity embedding from the input layer.
And then this O is your hidden state
your OBS your full obs embedding.
And these get combined with a hard
attentional function which is typically
like dotproduct plus soft max
>> or dotproduct arc max
>> and then you get your argument
selection.
This was from like 2018, 2019
45.
And then this was inspired by heavily by
the Dota architecture, trying to make a
cleaner version of that.
Um, for the most part, I would say.
>> All right. Fair enough. Fair enough.
>> Okay. PR
rebuild.
Do you just
>> show you one that crashed?
Where's the old build?
>> I I suspect that this thing is going to
crash on frame two.
>> Yeah.
>> Yours doesn't crash on frame two, right?
>> No.
>> Yeah. I think it's going to be revert
and merge. So, this could be OSTiff.
>> Yeah. See, this is frame one and it's
going to fault frame two doing nothing.
>> Yeah.
>> And the standalone didn't work either,
did it?
just merge your PR.
>> No,
>> like it's just
kind of sad honestly.
I hate this.
Okay.
Want to make sure we actually have this
clean.
Uh, yours has the same problem for me.
>> Yeah.
>> This is crash on frame two.
So then what you have this is
DPU you have, right?
Yeah, I should have
I've done it without the CPU flag.
>> Well, wait. You You can't have done it
without the CPU flag cuz you're on a
Mac, right?
>> Well, I have my metal kernels and
everything. So, have this [ __ ] crazy
>> set up on my Mac. But
and that kind of adds to the problem,
but
>> Okay. Okay, the rendering is decent, but
um
>> it's really dumb.
>> Is a random agent.
So I mean that could just be the CPU
policy is diverged.
I mean, it's not doing anything.
>> This is not the [ __ ]
The CLF flag was something else here for
the checkpoint line.
>> Was it?
>> Oddly. So,
>> I thought I changed it.
Yeah, it is just latest.
>> Yeah.
No, I think it's OSR send.
>> What? No, no, no. It has to be the OSR's
end. The um Huh?
This is I changed this is the I this is
in the last few days I simplified the
CLI.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's just
>> I definitely won't have those.
>> Yeah. But this this shouldn't change
anything for you.
>> Yeah.
>> Like this was just this is global change
to like
>> this shouldn't have broken anything. I
mean we can render it cleanly on CPU but
on GPU for some reason it renders the
first frame in bolts.
>> Yeah.
Even with like four M's or something,
it's still sect bolting.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is very on frame two.
>> What happens there? Doesn't really
bring any bells for me.
So, it's some stupid platform specific
thing, which is lovely.
>> Yeah,
>> we'll see. At least now we have a clean
starting point where it doesn't have a
million damn changes.
>> Yeah.
It's been state of all headless just
fine on my on the box. But
>> well, headless doesn't render at all.
>> What's that?
>> Headless doesn't render at all, right?
>> No, it doesn't.
>> That is confusing as well though cuz
headless could be like headless
rendering.
>> Yeah.
>> Mean no render or something.
Yeah, it shouldn't be that hard to
triage to be honest. It's uh
pretty cool.
>> This was how I originally thought that
the
end was going to have to be written for
like a big MMO environment. I thought it
was going to have to model like
I thought this was going to have to
follow the model of a actual MMO server
where like each server has
like a couple environments and then
there are clients that have to connect
to it.
It was completely the wrong design, but
nobody I mean nobody had any idea what
they were doing with the RL info back
then.
This right here, what I called the IO
problem
is like this is still the big the main
issue today of like representing OBS and
actions sely
>> in what sense?
entity encoder, cons like flat, entity
decoder, like all the different things
you need to fit the shape of the data.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it makes sense.
IO
input and output, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. The problem is at both ends.
I mean, the net that I came up with is
basically what we end up using.
Oh, Lib Cuda.
>> It actually apparently this is some sort
of weird deep crash.
Nope. Dota is not open source sadly.
They do have a very nice paper that has
a lot of details,
but not everything.
Apparently, this is actually some sort
of
weird
significant problem.
Yeah. And it's hard to imagine why.
Like the language model has to be
missing something. Fairly obvious.
>> So it's using Mesa.
Wait,
why would it be using Mesa
instead of the Nvidia drivers?
That's kind of weird, isn't it?
>> I don't know. H.
So, it's using Mesa and Nvidia drivers
at the same time potentially.
Yeah, something's
over complicated here.
Egg faults in frame two. Wait, he
headless egg faults.
Uh,
>> Say false as well.
M
>> is a big inferno state.
Now it's trying you limit again.
I tried with vecto total agent smaller
though.
>> This is what I mean though, right? Like
it's and this is why I want to help with
this because like it the end has to get
through the last 10% of Jank and just be
stable and sane.
Yeah.
Oh, this is just such a silly problem to
have. Like it wouldn't happen if I had a
had a proper Nvidia B here.
Well, I mean, I kind of get it in the
sense like this is why I decided to
provide actually good CPU eval
so that people could at least have that
work locally.
>> It just it was I looked at it there's no
there's absolutely no sane way that we
can do multiple backends, right?
Puffer's 10k total lines. It's 5k lines
of backend total for puffer. Having
multiple backends would just blow it up
massively. And there's no way to do like
a backend agnostic thing either when
stuff is this performance sensitive.
>> Yeah, it's true.
>> Like the tiny grad solution is kind of
cool, but like we're faster.
>> Yeah. It ends up being this like whole
tinkering exercise. Like again, you
can't really make it just work.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
the CPU eval though is good. Like that
does just work.
>> Yeah. I don't know what's up with the
model being different. Um, and that's
one of the things I actually need the
CUDA to work for because then if you the
CUDA works, you can automate the check.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I'll check out the CPU path
tomorrow as well.
>> Mhm.
>> The most reasonable way to do this
moving forward.
>> Mhm.
>> Nowadays, I don't really train anything
at all on my MacBook, so it's like
whatever. Initially when I got started
playing playing with
>> faster
it is. Yeah. There's no two way about
it.
>> This is why I said like yeah you can do
a lot of work to get metal to be like
okay but it's going to underperform a
10-centent per hour G Nvidia GPU.
>> Yeah it just doesn't have the bandwidth
and that's that's fine. It's not really
what it's built for to to be fair. So,
but yeah. Yeah, I don't know. And it
then it enters that territory if it's
like fair enough. It's if it's three
times faster than the CPU, but it's
still slow, then
>> who cares?
>> But it would be something nice for
somebody who can't afford to rent the
GPU box, for example. And you know, I'm
thinking young guys maybe who've just
got their like MacBook from school or
whatever and want to play around with
Puffer, but I guess then they just do it
with the CPU anyway.
>> Yeah, it's it's tough to like cuz we
just we know how important the iteration
cycle time is. So giving you something
that's going to be 120th of the speed of
a GPU is just not worth it.
Yeah, it doesn't really fit the
branding, does it? Either it's like
>> iteration speed over
over almost anything
they just run at [ __ ] 5k SPS on your
local machine.
>> You can get it more than 5K, but like
still
>> Yeah, you definitely can. But still it's
um but then again it's how I got started
and it's uh you know if somebody else
goes through that same journey then so
be it. But
>> yeah I we're trying to make it really
easy for people to do like the setup for
uh like remote
10centent an hour GPU and then pull
model render local. We're trying to make
that really easy.
Um,
>> yeah,
>> it's just it's tough because like I
guess technically now parts of our
algorithm are simple enough that we
could maybe ship an okay training back
end, but like we have to keep that whole
thing in sync with the GPU back end. And
practically there's not really a way to
do that while sharing any real amount of
code.
>> there's some stack [ __ ] Alec,
register for prick.
Yeah, it would be best devx if you could
just provide the compute as well or rent
out the compute, but then you'd be
turning puffer into a some kind of B2C.
>> Yeah, we just like get a bunch of
servers and rent out the compute.
But that's uh
>> I mean that would be a disaster, right?
Like
>> it would be the good thing would be that
like the models are small and that
compute would go a long way. So
>> yeah,
>> but yeah, it's just like each
one of a 5090.
>> Yeah, but it's just all of this hardware
is so expensive now. Doesn't really like
the market currently doesn't care about
puffer being fast. They just want to
cram a [ __ ] mass of language models
in there and call it a day.
But every star puffer gets its um more
attentions to this
>> two star puffer.
>> Yeah.
>> 6.3k stars
>> that's been going up.
>> Yeah. We got the chart here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I remember I remember
remember it being less than 2K. But
>> it's funny cuz this point right here is
when I started working on it full-time.
>> Like right here when it has like a 100
stars.
I think there was like
>> Which came first?
>> You working full-time or the or the
stars? What happened here exactly?
>> Well, I finished I graduated my PhD
here.
Yeah.
>> And I started working on it full-time,
right? It was just like it was basically
just a set of rappers and scripts that
we used for some of our competitions
before that.
>> How did people find out
>> about Puffer? Well, I started promoting
it and stuff, right? It full-time.
>> Yeah, initially when it started growing.
>> Yeah. I mean, before that when it got
the first 100 stars, that was just from
like competitions.
>> Yeah. because you know
>> that like point there.
>> Well, I I started working on it
full-time and posting about it on
Twitter and like doing the Discord and
doing live streams and stuff.
>> Did you have some kind of following
already at that point?
>> Not really. Like a thousand maybe on
Twitter.
>> Oh,
>> but I sort of built it from there.
Now we have 16 people watching us watch
a terminal debugging utterly stupid
things.
>> Yeah,
>> which is kind of impressive honestly
given the uh how boring this currently
is because I'm s I'm sure as hell bored.
>> Yeah, 16 people watching this is real
loyal to that's that's for sure. Yeah,
I've had it be like 40 during the week
on uh I think this weekend it was 40 a
couple of the days when I was doing like
actual dev stuff.
>> Yeah, wines is not the type of content
that you know blows up or anything.
>> That doesn't have to be right. Just need
to get a few people interested enough to
build some uh some RLNs.
>> Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, rather not get into that like you
know if you added some kind of subway
surfer
somewhere on the screen then maybe the
youngsters would get interested but
>> we have the puffer already. That's
that's good enough, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> And I can do this.
>> Oh yeah. My kids always get the puffer
puffer fish.
I've been trying to get them upgraded a
little bit with some more animations,
but then there were some modeling
screw-ups in the process that I'm trying
to figure out um that I didn't catch
before I took the handover from the
artists. So,
>> YouTube recommended your channel
randomly. I do have a couple things on
uh on my channel like my thesis defense
is on there, the iceberg videos on
there, have a few pieces of long form
content
and then like thousands of hours of
streams.
What's happening? We're kind of just
stuck because there's a really weird
rendering bug with Runescape and they
train um we can make them train like 3x
faster than current with async and with
um buffering and some different params.
Both the RSM can get over a million SPS
train. I think that they'll probably end
up sweeping down to 600 to 800k to still
double the current perf. Um,
there's some weird screwy thing with
rendering and
not been able to figure it out. It works
on Volo's machine.
>> The latest
hypothesis here is that
>> this thing seems to think it's something
super deep.
Yeah, this now fail before really
initialization when Linux has no usable
X11 display. X11 display is not
something else.
>> We do have usable.
I mean, is it something if this ends up
being something utterly stupid like Ra
called in the wrong order after all
this, I'm going to be mad, but whatever.
I would believe this is possible that
we're like overflowing stack
some more jank.
It's probably the same bug as it's been
the whole time because we've basically
always just had some weird rendering
issue
>> that was like different on yours versus
mine.
>> Yeah.
>> Like every single time I've looked at
this project.
>> Yeah.
>> Which has been probably the main reason
I haven't been able to like even just go
do some runs is because I can't just
render it and check it easily.
I
>> mean, we didn't even used to have the
CPU rendered working nice.
Yeah, I got to focus on that. To be
honest, this is like wasting time here
on all of this
>> all the silly stuff.
>> Sometimes you have to be willing to
waste time on the silly stuff to get it
to like actually
>> work.
>> I do think that the encoder stuff will
be much more interesting and probably
quite useful.
I need to figure out the uh attention
encoder stuff as well. Maybe that that
could be a thing.
Uh this is Volo Tim. This is uh Volo has
done the Runescape environments
and we can maybe show them off in a
minute or two if we can fix this weird
bug. Uh, we've both been looking at this
thing and trying to figure this out for
the last hour.
Okay, this is what the end is supposed
to look like. I don't know if that was a
seg fault.
It seems to think it no longer segs.
It was clear, wasn't it?
Uh it rendered a few frames. It it
actually rendered a few frames there.
>> Okay. Fair enough.
>> First CUDA policy forward after the
first window frame.
>> It is not
Okay, so it says the pathf finding was
overflowing keep somewhere.
That doesn't make any sense. I've been
debugging this
all day long here and it's been working
just fine.
Let's see.
Well, this actually does render now.
Yeah, but it's nonsensical.
around.
>> [ __ ] Is this
like zero or something?
>> Well, it's going up waves.
Is it swapping between M's or something?
>> Yeah, it seems. Oh,
Yeah, I don't know. I'm looking at
something weird here.
I have a new PR up 657, but I don't
really see what this
>> this renders.
It is.
Hang on a second. Let me let me check
one thing. All right. Uh,
we'll be right back.
Hey, Glitzy.
So, this thing is cranking through waves
and uh the rendering doesn't make any
sense.
can't really begin to understand what's
going on here.
NPC models are warped as well.
Something weird.
Can you tell the board to take a look at
6.7
>> six uh the PR?
>> Yeah, new one.
there's nothing here that would make
sense
for this type of problems.
It seems to be just laser focused on
this like frame two crash.
>> It did figure something. I do think that
there it is very possible that there is
a uh
overflow or some weird jank.
>> I mean, that's the only thing I could
think of that could end up being like
platform specific.
>> Yeah.
Well, the language models agree with
each other and that's a recipe for
disaster at that point.
>> You know, something's going to go away.
>> Mhm.
The one problem with the the new hunter
thing is it's like it costs about as
much as chinning.
>> It does. It's very expensive, is it?
>> Well, cuz people have to catch the
things just like chins.
Oh,
>> the ticks that you use as bait.
>> And you can catch more of them per an
hour, but you use like two of them per
catch.
>> Yeah.
>> Also, the pricing has been very very
weird on them. It's like oscillating by
500 GP per day somehow,
>> which doesn't make
or fishing.
>> H
>> Did you do the wood cutting or fishing
in Berium?
>> Um the fishing there's no way to AFK.
The wood cutting they did add an AFK
thing, but it's not great and it's also
not super fast. I did um iron I actually
I did both wood cutting and fire making
on iron woods. Just like bring a tinder
box and do the um forestry campfire.
>> Oh, okay. I think the fishing you can
kind of AFK like you just
>> they have AFK prevention on it.
>> Really?
>> Mhm.
>> But it lets you go for like hour long.
>> No, it like it's if you if you miss too
many catches, it stops giving XP and you
just stand up and stop catching them as
well.
>> I tried that.
>> Yeah, that's annoying. Now for fishing,
you have the the sailing AFK stuff like
angler fish for example. I think you can
AFK for like 30 minutes even or
something.
>> Yeah, it's very slow though.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. It's like shooting stars pretty
much.
>> I found those not great. I did my uh
mining to 98 on
what's the thing? Uh calcified deposit.
Oh yeah,
>> it's faster.
And I left 600k XP for the day.
>> Oh yeah.
And let's hope it's fixed.
And let's hope it hasn't messed with
puffer.
>> is it default like above?
>> No, default should be the Oh, server
speed,
but you can bring it down with
>> it's like reasonable, but it's still
jumping around. Yeah, this doesn't seem
correct still. Like even when you speed
it up, it remains kind of smooth.
>> Well, it's it is actually rendering at
too fast of a rate.
>> Yeah, but it was still like jumping
around. It's just not
it works. Let me
>> try this. Let me just make sure it's not
crossing wires between ends.
>> Yeah.
It's still jumping, isn't it?
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Ow.
>> It's probably It's got to be like
skipping steps on
This is the shape of the command that I
use here on my MacBook. But you're
saying the global change should
take it away from this. I don't even
know if it's encounter inferno or
anything. So that is for the CPU one
that you have.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I guess if the encounter does
something then maybe. But yeah, we
changed it so you don't need dash model.
It it's just um
it should just be the the model.
Either way though, I need the CUDA thing
to work.
Then
>> this is the default on how we run it as
well because the CPU one actually it's
additional sources of error because the
CPU is like a it's a copy of the net for
CPU.
Is the uh fast build not a thing
anymore?
>> That's default.
>> It's default. Yeah,
>> the local was replaced with d-debug. Uh
I there have docs I have some docs um
that I need to push but it's I just
simplified and merged all of the
redundant commands so it's like a way
simpler CLI surface.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't really value having it
like keeping stuff backwards compatible
across versions or anything. I just try
to keep everything the simplest it can
possibly be. Every version
eval is stepping every display frame.
So it runs 60 ticks per second.
Do you have this base db base
um arguments though
the current
>> I have this what argument
>> uh base load model path is
what it's showing here
>> that it probably left a fall back in
that needs to be deleted.
This is what it's suggesting now.
>> I mean, you can check with like breakout
if you want. It should just be like
build breakout- cu if you want the CUDA
version/puffer
trainer eval. the latest
see whether it rebuilt or not.
It also just takes a very awkward amount
of time to load everything.
>> Yeah, that's weird.
>> Looks like mostly correct.
>> Yeah,
it's a bit slow, but
>> well, that's the actual tick rate,
right?
I can do like
>> brain rate wise
>> this is now I hit the zero button twice.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, this is definitely the transform.
>> Is he using pillars? No, it's just god
flicking.
Cool.
So, I mean, we actually have this
and watch this a little bit and then we
can try. Let's see if the CPU one works.
Now, we can actually test it. We have
Colo to test as well.
refers to free millers.
>> Freezing miller is valid.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> It also cleans them around a bit.
>> It actually bothers with the barrage
nibs as well.
>> Uh your health orb doesn't have the
percent drain.
>> Yeah, it doesn't. And run energy is not
really working like intended either. But
>> well, the health.
>> Yeah.
>> I also Does it just not Oh, it does use
prayer, but the orb doesn't drain.
>> Yeah, it uses it sometimes, but it
doesn't have the tools to kind of one
click. I've given it the um the action.
So,
>> it can do it can like double can it
click like range and then click range
mage to like turn off and then turn on
mage?
Uh
switches.
>> The way I'm doing one clicking is just
that it when it refreshes a a prayer,
then that's basically a one click. So it
doesn't drain the points for that.
>> Ah,
>> it calls like it's already praying range
and it calls prey range again, then it,
you know, once.
>> Okay. So it doesn't have to double. I
see.
Yeah,
>> that's actually kind of a nice thing to
leave in there intentionally to break
people from trying to like bot inferno
with this just if they're dummies.
>> Yeah, that's true. But it's also like
just I don't really feel like we're
introducing a lot of utility into the
action space. If we do that, like give
it double clicks to actually do it. Just
kind of feels silly.
>> Yeah, but remember the people that are
like messing with this typically have no
idea what the hell they're doing.
Yeah, true.
>> That was a harder wave already. 24 the
first.
>> It is using all of its supplies on this
policy.
>> Yeah, my local one doesn't use any
supplies at all.
>> I think that this Well, this one wasn't
great. Remember, this one was just a uh
>> Oh, yeah. This was a quicker one.
>> It does have non-zero win rate, though.
>> Yeah. Oh,
>> it wasn't quicker. This is before I
messed with the args, but this is not
tuned for 5.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, this was average wave well
into the 60s still. So,
>> I wonder how two bruise.
>> Yeah. Well, I've noticed that it just
makes no sense how they learn to use the
bruise basically or any of the supplies.
It could be that basically like he uses
all of the supplies very early on and
then it just like flawlessly flicks and
everything towards the end.
>> You gave it blowpipe
because it'll go flex. So it doesn't
need eldrich. It doesn't need SGS like
>> Yeah.
Yeah. This is like the very very basic
max max set that I've I've given.
I guess now you have more range gear as
well. But
>> it is somewhat annoying that for like
inferno whatever it's so nice to have
Ellie and Kodai which you wouldn't have
otherwise.
>> Yeah,
>> actually nobody's know if I would ever
bring code I'd probably bring Eldrich,
right?
>> Yeah. I don't think people really bring
this stuff anymore.
I don't think Elijah e either like just
has very little use nowadays in the
game. Yeah, that was still good.
>> It's like going on the defense in this
game is kind of silly. Like it's it's a
tough problem game design wise for them
for sure. It's like rarely you have any
reason to like get damage reduction on
yourself.
>> Uh I think it's mostly because they
don't do um chip damage, right?
Yeah, true. But even then, it's like if
something does cheap damage to you, then
you just rather kill it as soon as
possible so that it no longer deals that
damage.
>> They could definitely tune the attack
rate such that defense would um or the
attack
uh bonuses such that having better armor
would be a pretty decent reduction.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's true. Yeah, there
would have to be some kind of inflection
point in that where like
defense would make more sense, but I
don't know. It's not very compatible
with the idea that you have to be able
to solo everything like if you don't
have a tank kind of like roll.
>> Well, I mean, that's like that's on them
for doing it that way.
Yeah,
>> there was all sorts of cool tech that
like could have been a thing, but
because the balance never got done. Like
I think when Todd came out, people were
trying, well, what if we just have one
dude with a bull work who's just going
to tank verick melees, right? And then
nobody has to tank range or mage hits.
Like that was pretty cool.
>> Yeah, that would be fun actually. But
>> Right.
>> But yeah, it's just not that type of
game to be honest. So Probably you've
seen those like mega scale chambers.
>> Mhm.
>> Where you have the ball guys just uh at
the edges of the room
>> hanging the the head.
>> I guess the idea is not
>> it's at 43.
>> What's that?
>> It is at wave 43. It has not used the
bruise.
Yeah. Yeah. Right. Like it just used the
bricks in those.
>> It did use the restore doses and it's
used all its bastion doses which is bad.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. But even that like I was think
I've thought about that alone. It's just
like
I really know what it does. It doesn't
really get that like
necessity. like it doesn't see this at
all in the same way that we do where
it's like it gets harder towards the end
and we kind of want to save supplies or
whatever. It just has no
kind of understanding of that it seems.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's that's a very like common
theme between all of these source and my
experience just uses the supplies in
some completely silly way always.
blowpiping a major for some reason or is
it maging a major? What the hell is
that?
>> Oh, no. It blood barrage. It blood
barges though. It does blood barrage to
heal.
Supplies are looking pretty grim if
you're in this position as a player.
there like
maybe 10 people in the world that can do
Inferno on these
on this.
>> Yeah,
>> I remember Wuks was the first one to do
like no supply inferno.
Yeah. Or just maybe this week even
uploaded the like no prayer.
>> There were apparently three. The crazy
thing is apparently there three people
who've done it now. Three or four people
who've done no prayer.
>> Yeah. I think even somebody did it years
ago already. I think I've seen an old
>> I don't know if they finished it. They
got to Zuck on no prayer.
>> Oh yeah. It was unpredictable. That guy.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It was that guy. I think
Port Kazard was the first to actually
finish it maybe
>> and then there were two other guys and
then Exacted as well.
>> I'm pretty sure Unpredictable did maybe
six jobs without overheads or something
like that.
>> W did it with uh potatoes, I think.
>> Oh.
>> Um yeah, the agent has pretty much the
best case inventory setup, right? Uh
except for you didn't give it the new
range am
>> it's like one or two Tibo maxes. So
>> pretty significant.
>> I don't have mine yet.
>> You know I've been doing maggot king
with the elder mall that I got.
>> Not a very fun boss that one
>> actually. I thought it was awful and
like the punish didn't make any sense
and it turns out I had scythe on the
wrong attack style and it only lets you
punish on crush.
>> Oh, here you're going to love this,
right? If you just want to farm that
thing
>> where Serel and inoculation bracelets,
you can literally AFK it.
>> Oh, yeah. I saw a video about a CA. I
think it's even like one of the I don't
remember which CA.
>> Yeah, there is actually. There are a
couple CA where it helps.
>> Yeah. Yeah. just stand still in poison
or whatever and you just don't care.
>> I still have to run DPS K cuz I think
that range will probably be better
without conflictions
cuz the bracelet takes love slot.
>> They made the loot better as well,
didn't they?
>> They do curriculum inventory.
>> I don't think randomizing or curriculum
inventory would help at all here because
it doesn't really change how you play
very much. I think the main thing is
that the action space is not good for
this inventory setup. Like your gear can
move around as you switch a little bit
cuz you have a two-handed. The thing is
you have two-handed shield. Like you
have staff and shield, one hand, one
hand. Then when you switch that with
your two-handed weapons, you can move
stuff around, right?
Yeah, it doesn't really care about the
ordering of the items in the inventory.
But
>> um
>> it might not be that to be fair.
>> I'm definitely about just not giving any
supplies at all or randomizing the
supplies a bit 60, man.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it's doing Let's actually
see if it dies in 63, for example,
because it's
I don't know.
>> Can you give it speed
>> I still need to do all the inferno
inferno achievements.
>> Why can't I see their projectiles?
Yeah. What's going on? Is it
>> This is 62. Oh, it died on 62.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> And that's pretty damn good for not even
being properly
>> I'm like I'm this to me this is now
sweepable and iterable, which is what I
wanted. Let's see if Ko works real
quick.
Oh yeah, I have this old
scaffolding things here. Straining
wheels. Current set is Artmax DVT for
Target.
You can only imagine what that's for.
is spoon feeding the information about
Yeah. Yeah. By the way, this um setup
that you're using right now is the best
in slot one for
>> Mhm.
>> this particular turbo anemia.
>> Okay. Now, apparently whatever change we
made now works for both of these.
Uh this is
>> That's interesting. This is the budget.
>> The hell do you What the hell setup is
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Why does it have two fangs?
>> Well, initially I got started just like
trying to
>> Wait, it has two fangs.
>> I Okay,
>> it literally has two fangs.
>> I have not tested on this budget setup.
This is the one that I run this like max
setup.
>> But yeah, that was funny. Oath plate
empty inventory slots. I think some
sprites are maybe not exported here.
>> You got to give it at least like an
extra couple of potions. And it doesn't
even have heart.
>> It's in wave nine.
>> Uh I don't understand. No, that's got to
be your curriculum randomizing it to
wave.
>> It's just something the start wave has
to be like in the config. Something's
messed up here now.
Well, at least now we can test stuff.
>> Yeah, but now it's spawning. Like it
doesn't have any restores. I suppose
it's not going to claim.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I don't really know what this is
about.
>> Wait, you gave it What the hell do you
use Elder Maul here for?
>> Oh,
>> you can also one you can oneot the
archer if you want.
>> Oh, okay. But it's for soul defense
reduction.
>> Okay,
>> that's like max up or max up.
>> That's cool.
Venador very needed. Yeah.
>> There's some jank with the manticor
still the animations. It's a bit like
>> That's cool though.
>> Even like lining those um the
projectiles that you see on top of the
manicore after it's armed. It was such
like you can see they they spin around
like different axis. So it's just such a
pain in the ass to get those lined up
>> with the real game.
>> It's cool though. This is escape sim.
>> This is definitely cool. It's like
inferno is mostly, you know, it's just
boarded from the trainer or whatever.
But this is kind of like this has been
tough work this whole
>> scratch. Yeah, this is a lot.
>> Yeah,
>> they not have they don't have collo in
the sim at all.
>> They don't. No, it's not open source.
>> Oh, this wait this is only soul. Yeah,
they don't have any waves and yeah, the
code isn't exist for this. So,
>> Oh, okay.
>> That's also not a very good sim in
general. Like, you know, barely.
>> No, no, no. That's not Yeah. Where can I
play?
>> That one I like.
>> You can pull puffer, I suppose. It's
mostly for the agents to play.
What is this? We're going to play it.
Yeah, you can use the human mode if you
want. Like you can play.
>> It's a little janky. Like I guess it's
We need to get I think it needs to be
like faster actually. Here. Can we do
uh OS call the um If I do CPU, is it
less janky?
>> I would think so. I for me locally it
doesn't doesn't lag at all. The frame
rate is uncapped. So
it feels surprisingly good. It's of
course if you play all you you
immediately tell the difference between
the animations but
>> Mhm.
>> But it feels reasonably good already.
Like I can play sim actually in this and
do well.
>> Okay. So this is human mode.
Okay. So, this is H. Oh, yeah. This is
not bad at all.
>> Which one am I supposed to melee the
ranger?
I cannot drop anything.
Shadow maybe.
Oh, I do have shadow. Okay.
>> Is the hitbox for this one?
>> Okay. So, now here's Jaguar
and now mage prep.
Uh,
>> you can do one, two, one, two, three hot
keys for the uh inventory. And
>> okay,
>> those are just the ones that I used
myself. So, I don't know which ones you
use, but
>> it is a little off here. It's definitely
a little laggy.
It shouldn't be
could be integration.
Yeah, there's definitely a lag on it.
Okay, so then we have this dude,
which I suppose you can shadow.
Wait, I'm so confused. You have you
bring shadow, but you don't bring mage
gear
cuz you
>> completion occult. This is the like
minimum setup that you need to oneshot
the berserker.
>> I see. You start each wave with this
what you've got on right now and they
just one shot the berserker immediately.
>> Many mayhem.
>> I think you also need augur to oneot.
>> Oh, you don't apparently
>> I can't I please not. No. And then I
think speedr runners here just benador
the u the major
>> you can't oneot with elder mall without
py I guess
and this is this is major so I need
ventor doesn't one shot unless you hit
both
>> solar flare is going wrong way I think
>> oh yeah that's the wrong way
>> yeah it goes kind of clockwise
Okay. And now this is this.
>> It is playable. It's very janky, but
it's playable.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh I think that this is mostly like not
even you though. I think that there's
just some lag with this specific
integration, man. Like I have like at
least 100 or 200 ms input delay.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I don't feel that.
The kind of like janky feeling comes
from elsewhere. It's not lag.
>> When I
>> This is Yeah, this is This is straight
lag.
>> This is like
>> I'm not entirely sure if you can skip
solar flare. I haven't tested manually.
>> Uh
>> or like over. Yeah,
it's I'm in sort of a jank position to
even try that.
>> Yeah.
>> Does it actually wait that long?
>> Oh, cuz it's every half. Yeah, it's
okay.
>> It gets faster um as you rank it up, but
>> I don't know. There's no reference for
that. Like I would need to measure it in
game to know for sure.
>> See?
Oh, I skip it.
I think I just skipped it, right?
>> Yeah, it did. It took
>> again.
>> Yeah, I skipped.
>> Yeah,
>> skip works.
>> And it just dies.
Okay.
I uh I think that's enough until I get
it to be.
Yeah, the jankiness is is just straight
lag in my case. So
>> yeah,
>> that seems doable. I think if we get it
to be like reasonably playable, it'll be
a lot better. So test I can like
>> Yeah, gonna have to work on that
>> tomorrow.
>> Uh there's nothing in source.
>> Oh, well it's um past 2 a.m. here, so
>> yeah. Thank you very much.
>> I think this is I mean, hey, I'm I'm
happy that we actually have this
integrated now even though there was a
whole bunch of dumb [ __ ] because
like we can actually start sweeping this
and I can start using this for tests. So
hopefully now this goes into the test
pool like Net Hack and we should start
to see a lot of progress very quickly.
>> Oh yeah, for sure. Yeah, I'm very
excited for it.
If you want to take a look at the
rendering, like let me know if if
there's something that can be changed
because we changed the way that the eval
loop works a little
>> and it might not be great for Runescape.
So, we might have to change a couple
things. But yeah, thank you V.
>> All right. Thanks. Have a great one.
>> You
okay? Well, that was great. Now we have
Now we have this whole end fixed I
think.
Oh, that's actually that works
perfect.
Oh, wait. No, that's not perfect. I need
to I still need to push.
That's very good though. Done.
Now we have Runescape.
Uh we have Runescape on here.
Perfect.
You're in the wrong place to ask that,
man.
Okay. Uh, let's see.
And leave this thing
Yeah, but I'm not vibe coding stuff, my
guy.
Well, this is technically this is
fishing for experiment results is what
this is.
No, I it just thinks very differently
from what you expect. Um,
okay. So, this is this is just
experiment going.
We have Volo stuff integrated. Med
hack's good. Um,
we got a few other fixes in this
morning.
Main thing is craft decks, which I got
to go check on now. What am I doing?
This is basically m a lot of this is
just maintenance and integration work
ahead of our next release.
Getting things up to the latest version,
sanity checking stuff, running some end
toend tests. Then the thing with the VA
was a weird render bug that we had to
cross platforms.
We will have to figure out the render
thing. I'll let Volo take a crack at
that
and probably sweep
We can probably sweep any of the RS
atoms at this point
um on the current encoder. That should
be fine.
four big complex unsolved ends that have
good baselines.
That's a really good place to be for
research.
It's a really good place to be for
other than this experiment may be
producing something worthwhile.
I think we're good
on
this real quick.
Empty encoder.
It's good so far.
Yeah, it's good so far.
There's still some work needed.
Yeah. So, Net Hack currently has a basic
entity encoder and entity decoder.
Um, Volo is missing. Volo has an entity
encoder,
but no entity decoder.
And then there's also the possibility of
uh improving
the entity decoder
and the entity encoder architecture as a
whole.
Yeah, I'm happy with this.
let me make sure I didn't break the main
train path.
Yeah, but the docks are small because it
is literally that simple.
This project is a continuation of my
thesis or rather it's an extension of
things I worked on during my thesis um
more broadly coupled with a heavy
emphasis on more engineering um systems
engineering and Perf
the docs actually believe it or not they
get smaller not longer in 50 because
some of the things that were confusing
and needed to be documented in 40 we
have just deleted or made simple. So now
they don't need docs
So in Puffer 5,
that's how you build and train. That's
it.
And then you just have some commands.
That's it. That's literally everything.
You don't even need this stuff at the
bottom. Realistically.
Here's some stuff on the design of the
library.
And then here's your tutorial on making
an N
that links you to a couple things, but
that's literally it.
It's literally just like
just go here and you have the whole
thing.
papers.
really old things.
Deal.
We'll fix this real quick and we'll call
it for today.
Why choose MMO?
I need to be niched to kit. No, there's
a huge amount of just like people doing
the same thing.
So, if that's what you want to do, I
don't know why you would do a PhD. The
point of doing a PhD is that you have a
lot of time to think about a problem.
I think I'm going to call it there. We
have
net hack from Finn integrated this week.
We've got both of those big Runescape
environments. We've got major stuff on
neural MMO 3 integrated.
Four environments that are hard that are
unsolved that we can use for testing.
We have a few more things that we
definitely need to do, but
I think overall this is this is quite
good. Um
I'm tired as well. I've been live for 4
hours plus more this morning. So I'm
going to call it. Thank you very much
folks for tuning in. Star Puffer on
GitHub. Support my work. Feed the
puffer.
And
we will uh hopefully be back tomorrow
working on a few more things.
Pre-release.